IN READY TO GO. GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME MY NAME IS LORENA
GONZALEZ IN THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REPRESENTING THE EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON LET THE NIGHT IN EQUITIES. I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US TODAY FOR SECOND
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BY THE
SELECT COMMITTEE TODAY WILL
HEAR FROM EXPERTS AND LATINA
PROFESSIONALS THAT HAE WORKED
IN HOLLYWOOD AND WILL SHUT
SHARE TESTIMONY ON THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND CHALLENGES THEY
FACED AS LATINOS WILL ALSO HEAR
FROM UPDATES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION. AND
THE NATIONAL HISPANIC MEDIA
COALITION ABOUT ANY EXISTING
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY
AND ADDRESS INEQUITIES LATINAS
AND OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS MAY FACE IN THIS
INDUSTRY. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
COUPLE OF HOUSEKEEPING THINGS
DO TOOK COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING PROTOCOLS WITH THEIR
LIMITED SPACE IN THE HEARING
ROOM FOR MEMBERS. WE HAVE SOME
ON THE LINE AS WELL AS SOME IN
THE ROOM. IF YOU'RE IN A
HEARING ROOM PLEASE ADHERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
MAINTAIN AT LEAST SIX FEET
APART. ALL INDIVIDUALS NEVER
MUST WEAR A MASK AND WE WILL
HAVE TWO PANELS TODAY WITH A
PERIOD OF TIME FOR MEMBER
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION AFTER
EACH PANEL. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE TAKEN AFTER THE SECOND PANEL
AND THE HEARING WILL END BY
ELEVEN AM. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
CALL THE TOLL FREE NUMBER AT
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE. FIVE SEVEN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO- TO. THIS NUMBER
CAN ALSO BE FOUND ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE UNDER
TODAY'S EVENTS. I'D LIKE TO
THINK MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
HERE TODAY AND TO THOSE WHO ARE
JOINING VIRTUALLY. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
DESPITE LATINAS MAKE UP 20% OF
POPULATION CALIFORNIA WE
CONTINUE TO BE EXCLUDED IN A
RACE AND MISREPRESENTED IN
MOVIES AND ON TV. WHEN WE ARE
SHOWN ITS OFF AND AS A
SUPPORTING CHARACTER NOT THE
LEAD A BEST FRIEND. POSSIBLY A
PROSTITUTE. A DRUG ADDICT FOR
SOMEBODY IN A GAME. WHEN THE
TEAMS ARE MISSING FROM SHOWS
AND MOVIES ARE ONLY DEPICTED
SURVEYS ARE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
AMERICAN CULTURE CAN BE
OVERLOOKED AN UNSEEN WHEN
LIFTING AS ARE MISSING BEHIND
THE SCENES AS WRITERS DIRECTORS
SHOW RUNNERS AND CREW MEMBERS
THIS IMPACTS WHAT STORIES ARE
TOLD IN THE SHAPES AND HOW THEY
ARE TOLD. WITH THAT- I'D LIKE
TO INVITE OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE TO GIVE OPENING
REMARKS IF THEY LIKE SAYS THAT.
ASSEMBLY WILL. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR FOR-
HOSTING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE I'M I'M PARTICULARLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION
AS VICE CHAIR ON THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT PORTS AND
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA-
COMMITTEE- IS A TOPIC THAT I
THINK ME AND MY AYE CHAIRWOMAN
SHARON QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY
WOMAN TRYING TO COOK SOME ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN AND
IN MY DISTRICT- WE HAVE A
GROWING HOLLYWOOD INDUSTRY
PRODUCTION FILMS MOVIE RANCHES-
AND I'M EXCITED TALK ABOUT THIS
TOPIC IS WAS PARTICULARLY AS- I
MADE THE PANDEMIC HAS DEEPLY
IMPACTED MY COMMUNITY AND
LATINOS IN HOLLYWOOD IN THE
INDUSTRY SO EXCITED TO TALK.
ABOUT THIS TOPIC TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE THANK YOU
IN AND GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE- AND AGAIN THANK YOU
TO. OUR CHAIRWOMAN
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER SUCH AN
IMPORTANT- DISCUSSION WHEN IT
COMES TO REPRESENTATION I WANT
TO SHARE JUST A FEW A
STATISTICS AS WE KICK IT OFF.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE USC
ANNENBERG INCLUSION INITIATIVE
PUBLISHED A REPORT EXAMINING
THE PREVALENCE OF LATINO
CHARACTERS ONSCREEN ACROSS
TWELVE HUNDRED TWELVE- TOP
GROSSING FILMS FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. I'M SORRY FROM
200-072-2000 EIGHTEEN. AND WHAT
THE REPORT FOUND IS INCREDIBLY
OUTSTANDING LIKE. OUT OF THE
TOP ONE HUNDRED GROSSING
DOMESTIC FEATURES IN THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS LATINO CHARACTERS
MAKE UP ONLY FOUR POINT 5% OF
ALL SPEAKING ROLES AND NAMED
CHARACTERS. ACROSS THE ONE
HUNDRED TOP GROSSING FILMS OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE FORTY
SEVEN FILMS WERE COMPLETELY
MISSING LET THE NO CHARACTER
SEVENTY FILMS WERE MISSING AT
THE NINTH. NINETY FIVE MOVIES
DID NOT FEATURE LATINO
CHARACTER WITH A DISABILITY
NINETY EIGHT WERE MISSING AT
THE IN ALSO IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY DOCUMENTING ANOTHER
KEY. FINDING THE RAZOR OF
LATINO ROLES IN POPULAR MOVIES
ONLY 4% OF DIRECTORS AND 3% OF
PRODUCERS IN THESE MOVIES FOR
LATINOS. ONLY ONE AT THE NOT
DIRECTOR WORKED ACROSS THE
TWELVE HUNDRED FILMS EXAMINED
47% OF THE TWELVE HUNDRED
MOVIES IN THE REPORT SAMPLE
COMPLETELY. ERASED LATINO
SPEAKING CHARACTERS FIND. THESE
THESE FINDINGS TO BE INCREDIBLY
TROUBLING CONSIDERING THE
LATINOS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
DEMOGRAPHIC IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
AT THE NEST. ARE THE TOP
POPULATION IN THE STATE AND SO
THIS THIS INITIATIVE FOR UNSEEN
APENAS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO REPRESENTATION WHEN WE SEE
OURSELVES. IN OUR. INFILL. AND
MY- IT'S INCREDIBLY AND- ENTER
OF HOW I SAW ARE TO. IN WHOLE.
TELLS ARE SO. SOMEOF TO FROM
THE PANELIST REALLY HAVE A
GROUP CONVERSE AND WE IN WAYS
THE NEW. FOR A AT THE NEST
THING YOU. THANK YOU AND I DO
SEE WE HAVE- SOME MEMBERS ALSO
VERGE TAT I'D LIKE GO TO IF
WANT CALL TO STARTING WITH THE
CHAIR OF OUR CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. CENTER
MADDIE AND THEN IT ALSO. HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- EVERYONE
WHO'S ON THIS. CALL YOU KNOW
THIS THIS COMMITTEE I'M SO
PROUD THAT THE LET THE NO
CAUCUSES- HELPING TO SPONSOR OF
THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF THE LEFT
THE NEST- UNSEEN LEVINE AS
INITIATIVE- AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF THE LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- GONZALEZ- WHO SAID. TOLD
US AND REMINDED US THAT WE HAVE
GOT TO SEE WHAT IS THE LIKE THE
IN THE EXPERIENCE AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT IT. SO FIRST IDENTIFY
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES QUANTIFY
THEM AND ULTIMATELY WE HAVE TO
GET TO THE POINT OF RESOLVING
THESE BIG INEQUITIES WE DON'T
WANT OUR DAUGHTERS. AND
GRANDDAUGHTERS IN THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF LET THE
INVESTORS FACE THE SAME HURDLES
WE ARE. AND I'M SO PROUD OF THE
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND THE ADVOCACY OF
EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE. THE CHANGE THAT
WE NEED- IT'S GREAT TO SEE SO
MANY PEOPLE INSPIRED AND
MOTIVATED BY THESE HEARINGS WE
HAD PREVIOUS- MEETINGS
DISCUSSIONS HEARINGS ON
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. AND ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THE ECONOMIC AND
HEALTH IMPACT ON LATINOS DURING
COVERT NINETEEN- LOOKED INTO
LAW AND POLICIES THAT NEED TO
BE CHANGED- I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE TESTIMONY TODAY ON UNSEEN
LATINOS IN HOLLYWOOD. I'M
REALLY EAGER TO HEAR FROM THESE
AMAZING PANELISTS BECAUSE THEY
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF LOBBYING
US PAST PRESENT. AND FUTURE
THAT WILL HELP MAKE HOLLYWOOD
AND THE ENTERTAINMENT HAVE MADE
HOLLYWOOD IN THAT IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS.
SUCCESSFUL SOME OF OUR- MOST
WELL KNOWN. NAMES LIKELY
SOMEONE IN ON JENNIFER LOPEZ-
DIRECTOR BUT THE SECOND SO ARE
ARE PART OF OUR HISTORY AS LET
THE MASK BUT. THERE'S SO MANY
BEHIND THE SCENES THINGS LIKE
THEM AS THEY DESERVE THE SAME.
AND ARE SUPPORT FOR ECONOMIC
AND PROFESSIONAL WELL BEING SO
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF WORK IS GREAT WORK
AND FOR THE PANELISTS- WHICH IS
GOOD ASK YES AN A MINUS. THANK
YOU WE NEXT WE'LL GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER ASH KALRA%
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN JOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIRS.
IN ORDER TO BE PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE SPECIALLY GIVEN THAT
THE COMMUNITY ARE REPRESENTED
HERE IN SAN JOSE- IN ON THIS
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY IT'S ONE I
THINK THAT WE'RE SEEING A
RECKONING I THINK IN A GOOD WAY
IN HOLLYWOOD REGARDING
REPRESENTATION CERTAINLY IS
MEMBER THE API CALL BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
THEY'RE NOT. A CLEARLY WHEN IT
COMES AFTER IT REPRESENTATION
IS ABOUT NOT JUST IN QUANTITY
BUT IN QUALITY AN ACTUAL RAPTOR
DECISION I THINK THAT WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE- I'M SUFFICIENT
UNSEEN LATINOS. THAT'S PART OF
IT WELL IT'S NOT JUST THE
NUMBER OF LATINOS THAT WE SEE
IN CRITICAL ROLES ARE IMPORTANT
ROLES BUT HOW TO DEPICTED AND I
THINK THAT WE ALL HAVE TO TAKE
ACCOUNT- TO THE ROLE THAT WE
PLAY IN THAT AND THE COMMUNITY
I REPRESENT I KNOW THIS ISSUE
THAT MATTERS TO I'M- SPECIALLY
BEING HERE IN SILICON VALLEY
WHERE. I'M NEED TO ISSUE UNSEE
LEVINE AS PLAYS OUT IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS- HERE IN SILICON
VALLEY- IN SO- REALLY YOU HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY
BEING THE CAPITAL OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ISN'T BUT ONE OF MY
THANK YOU CHAIRED THE MEMBERS
FOR. THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE PANELISTS.
THANK YOU. I DO TO POINT-
YESTERDAY. HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHAIRMAN
OF OUR CONGRESSIONAL HISPANIC
CAUCUS JOAQUIN CASTRO.
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS WHO IS
ALSO ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL- ARE
HISPANIC CAUCUS HAS BEEN.
TAKING THIS ISSUE UP- NOT JUST
FOR LATINOS BUT LATINOS IN
GENERAL IN HOLLYWOOD AND SO
IT'S GREAT. THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON THIS AND SO MANY MULTIPLE
LAYERS I KNOW HE'S DONE SOME
REALLY FANTASTIC GROUND
BREAKING WORK. IN REALLY TRYING
TO HOLD- FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
LACK OF REPRESENTATION SO THAT.
THEY SHOULD JUST BE SEEN AS AN
EXTENSION OF THEIR GREAT WORK-
AND WE'RE GLAD TO BE ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND START OUR PANEL SO WE'LL
GET THROUGH THE FIRST FEW
PANELISTS- THEY'LL TALK FOR
ABOUT THREE MINUTES AND THEN-
WHAT WE WILL OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA START
WITH DR ANA CRISTINA REHMAN.
THE DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AND
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AT UCLA. AND
CO AUTHOR OF THE ANNUAL
HOLLYWOOD DIVERSITY REPORT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING- THE
WORK I'LL BE DISCUSSING TODAY
AS PART OF A MAJOR PROJECT ON
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTR
CONDUCTED AT UCLA WITH MY CO
AUTHOR DR DARNELL HUNT
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES AND
DEAN OF SOCIAL SCIENCES OUR
RESEARCH EXAMINES RACE
ETHNICITY AND GENDER
REPRESENTATION IN TV AND FILM
AND ITS RELATIONSHIP TO THE
BOTTOM LINE. TODAY'S
SPECIFICALLY ALL DISCUSS THE
FINDINGS FROM OUR FILM REPORT
THAT WE RELEASED YESTERDAY AND
OUR TEAM REPORT THAT WE
RELEASED LAST FALL. DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF FILMS TO ME
HOW LARGE A BUDGET TO ASSIGN TO
THEM HOW THEY WILL BE MARKETED
AND WHO WILL BE AT THE
DIRECTORIAL HOW ARE MADE BY
HOLLYWOOD EXECUTIVES. IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE FOUND THAT THESE
DECISIONS CONTINUE TO BE
DOMINATED BY WHITE MEN. THERE
IS ALMOST NO LAND NEXT
REPRESENTATION REGARDLESS OF
GENDER WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE
SUITES AND HOLLYWOOD. AMONG
FILM EXECUTIVES AT THE ELEVEN
MAJOR AND MID MAJOR STUDIOS
THERE IS NO LAND NEXT
REPRESENTATION AT ALL. AMONG TV
EXECUTIVES AT THE SEVENTY FOUR
STUDIOS AND NETWORKS THAT WE
EXAMINED THERE ARE NO LIVE NEXT
CEOS AND ONLY TO LEARN AN AXE
EXECUTORS AMONG SENIOR
MANAGEMENT. WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR
LESS THAN 1% OF THE TOTAL
POSITIONS AT THAT LEVEL. ONE IS
A LATINO CFO AND THE OTHER IS
THAT ENOUGH PRESIDENT OF
CONTENT CHIEF AND CHIEF
CREATIVE OFFICER FOR SEVENTEEN
THAT WORKS WITHIN. THE LARGER
CORPORATION. AMONG UNIT HEADS
THERE ARE LESS THAN 2% LAND
NEXT EXECUTIVES OVERALL AMONG
THOSE ELEVEN LINE NEXT
EXECUTIVES THERE ARE ONLY FIVE
THAT THE AS THAT ARE AT THE
UNIT HAD LEVEL. LENNOX'S ARE
ALSO SEVERELY UNDERREPRESENTED
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA AND
BEHIND THE CAMERA AS WELL-
WHAT'S MENTIONED EARLIER
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ARE SO LOW
FOR LATIN NEXT ACTORS THERE'S
OFTEN NOT MUCH GENDER DISPARITY
IN OUR FINDINGS. AMONG A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOR
THEATRICAL AND STREAMING FILMS
THAT WERE RELEASED IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE FOUND THAT THERE WERE
ONLY ABOUT 5% LAND NEXT LEADS A
LITTLE LESS THAN HALF OF THEM
WERE THAT THE MASS. IN ADDITION
THERE WERE ONLY ABOUT 6% LAND
NEXT ACTORS WHO ARE PART OF THE
MAIN CAST FOR THE FILM. AND
AGAIN A LITTLE LESS THAN HALF
OF THEM WERE THAT THE MASS SO
THAT THE YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT 2%
OF THE LEADS AND ABOUT 3% OF
THE TOTAL ACTORS. AMONG THE TOP
THEATRICAL AND STREAMING FILMS
THE NUMBERS ARE WORSE FOR LATIN
NEXT FILMMAKERS AND CONTENT
CREATORS. THERE WERE ONLY ABOUT
3% LAST NEXT DIRECTORS AND ONLY
ABOUT 3% LINE NEXT WRITERS. AND
THEY WERE ALL AT THE MOMENT. IN
THE 200-018-2000 NINETEEN TV
SEASON LAND NEXT LEADS
REPRESENTED ABOUT 6% 27% OF
LEADS AND BROADCAST CABLE AND
DIGITAL PLATFORMS. I'M BINDING
THEM ALL TOGETHER THERE WERE
ONLY FIFTEEN THAT BEING A LEADS
AMONG ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROGRAMS
ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS IN OUR
STUDY. WHICH COMPRISE ABOUT 3%
OF THE SHARE OF LEADS. IN THE
SAME TELEVISION SEASON LAST
NEXT ACTORS WHO ARE PART OF THE
MAIN CAST REPRESENTED 5% TO A
LITTLE OVER 6% OF ALL ROLES AND
BROADCAST CABLE AND DIGITAL
PLATFORMS. COMBINING THEM ALL
TOGETHER THEY WERE ONLY SEVENTY
EIGHT LATINOS WHO ARE PART OF
THE MAIN CAST OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
PLATFORMS IN OUR STUDY WHICH
COMPRISE LESS THAN 3% OF THE
SHARE OF TOTAL ACTORS. SO THE
NUMBERS ARE DISPIRITING BUT AS
I'M SURE THE OTHER PANELISTS
WILL SHARE THERE IS NO LACK OF
TALENT AMONG LETTING US JUST A
LACK OF OPPORTUNITY. AND A LACK
OF ACCESS WHICH WILL REQUIRE A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO CHANGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OVERARCHING PICTURE DR RAMON
AND PUTS IT IN PERSPECTIVE.
NEXT UP WE HAVE TIME YES THAT
SHOW CREATOR AND SHOW RUNNER
DIRECTOR OF VIVA ON STARS WHEN
YOU'RE READY. DUNYA I CAN'T
HEAR YOU. THAILAND LIKE PEANUTS
NO MORE. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
I LOVE HEARING DOCTOR ONE OTHER
TIME MY- HOLD ON TO A LOT OF
HER FINDINGS- TO SHAPE A LOT OF
WHAT I DO- I LET MYSELF BE A
CASE STUDY I DON'T I DIDN'T
BRING NUMBERS- I I'LL TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF AND-
THINGS AS I SEE HIM RIGHT NOW.
I WAS BORN IN AS MUCH AS YOU
KNOW A LOT- I WE MOVED TO
MCALLEN TEXAS WHEN I WAS. IN
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL
THAT I WENT TO BUST UNIVERSITY
TO STUDY THEATER- THEN I MOVED
TO CHICAGO AND I WAS GOING TO
BE AN ACTOR BUT WHEN I GOT
THERE. ARE ALL THE ROLES THAT I
WAS- THAT LET YEAH I WAS GOING
FOR. LIKE THE ONLY LINE THAT
THEY HAD WAS MOSTLY LIKE JUST
MISTER JOHNSON IT WAS THOSE
ROLES IT WAS STEREOTYPED AND-
AND- JUST LIMITED ROLES SO I
STARTED MY OWN. COMPANY AND ALL
THAT THE NAVIGATOR COMPANY
CALLED DR LUNA- AND WE WROTE.
WE WROTE OUR OWN STUFF-
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT DOES HAPPEN
IS IN THE EARLY AUGHTS WE- IT
WAS WHEN THE LATIN INVASION
EITHER CALLING OR J. LO CAME
OUT WITH ALL THE STUFF. IT WAS
LIKE THERE WAS- AND THEN THE
CENSUS HAD COME OUT AND THEY
SAID THAT WE WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR LIKE THINGS LIKE 11% OF. OF
ALL LIPSTICK LIKE OF PURCHASE
AS LIKE ALSO LET'S. LETS US
SELL TO LET THE MUSCLE
SOMETHING WAS HAPPENING IN THE
ZEITGEIST YOU KNOW. WHERE THEY
WERE- THE ROUTE THEY WERE SORT
OF TRYING TO LOOK TO US TO MAKE
YOUR COMPANY DID REALLY WELL.
WHICH THEN- THEN I STARTED
WRITING PLACE MYSELF I LEFT
ACTING- AND DOT. THAT GOT A
TEN. IN AND THEN I WAS. VERY
WELL PRODUCED AROUND THE
COUNTRY BUT EVEN THEN. IN THE
AMERICAN THEATERI COULDN'T
MAKE A LIVING- EVEN BEING THE
MOST PRODUCE LETTING A
PLAYWRIGHT IN THE COUNTRY. THE
AMERICAN THEATERS ALSO- MESSED
UP WHEN IT COMES TO YOU KNOW
EQUITY. OP SO I LOOKED TO ART
TELEVISION AS A LOT OF MY
FELLOW PLAY RIGHTS WERE DOING
SO THAT'S WHEN I CAME. OVER
HERE AND I GOT STAFF TO MY
FIRST SHOW ABOUT NEEDS. ARE
AND- THAT WAS A HARROWING
EXPERIENCE THERE ARE SOME
SYSTEMS IN PLACE IN IN
HOLLYWOOD I WAS I INTRODUCED
DIVERSITY HIGHER. AND I WAS
TOLD THE FIRST HOUR OF MY-
FIRST DAY AS A TV WRITER BY ONE
OF MY COWORKERS YOU DO NOT USE
THAT DIVERSITY HIGHER RIGHT.
AND I WAS LIKE I DIDN'T AND THE
FEAR THERE'S NOT THAT THERE IS
IN THAT ROLE SO I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THATMEANT- AND HE WAS
LIKE OH HONEY AND THAT- HONEY
STAYED WITH ME BECAUSE- THAT
HONEY STAYED THE WHOLE OFF ALL
THE MONTHS I WAS WORKING THERE
BECAUSE- IT. M. WHEN I FOUND
OUT WHAT DIVERSITY HIRE MANY
AMENDMENT THAT- I DIDN'T COST
THE STUDIO ANYTHING. WHAT I
HEARD IS YOU HAVE NO VALUE SO
MY I WAS THE ONLY LET THE NIGHT
BEFORE- MY SISTER GLORIA
CALDERON KELLETT SHOWRUNNER ONE
DAY AT A TIME- CAME- JOIN THE
ROOM I WAS THE ONLY THAT THE
NET AND STILL. HAD NO VOICE
THAT WAS LIKE. SORT OF- A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW IT WAS- THE
STATUS YOU KNOW OF THIS TV
WORLD THAT I HAD ARRIVED AND-
WHEN. GLORIA DID JOIN- AS A
JOKE OUR BOSS CALLED THE SPIC
AND SPAN. IN THE ROOM AND THIS
JUST HAPPENED A FEW YEARS AGO
YEAH SO LIKE IT WAS IT WAS
THAT'S LIKE THE- AND HE- IS THE
LAMBIC. THAT I ENTERED YOU KNOW
SO- I STUCK WITH IT BECAUSE
THERE WAS MONEY IN TV AND UP.
BECAUSE OF A SERIES OF THINGS
MAYBE A LITTLE PRAYER MCCARTY
YEAH AND LET ME GIVE HIM THE
ONE WHERE I GOT MY OWN SHOW- BE
THAT BUT I REALLY WANT TO
STRESS THAT I DON'T THINK I
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE SHOW IF
THE EXECUTIVE AT STARZ THE
NETWORK THAT- GIVE ME THE SHOT
WE'RE NOT NAME MONICA
FERNANDES. AND THAT GO YOU KNOW
LIKE WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE INSIDE THE CASTLE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE CHAMPIONING US BUT I DID
AND SO I WAS ABLE TO GET MY
SHOW UP WITH AN ALL LATINO
EXPERT LET THE NAY I USE THE
TERM. GENDER BECAUSE OF TERM
INTERCHANGEABLY. LET THE NECK-
AT STAFF WRITING STAFF- THEN BY
THE SECOND. SEASON ALL THAT THE
NET DIRECTORS- BY THE THIRD
SEASON ALL. RIGHT LET THE NINE
HISPANIC EDITOR STUART BUT
STILL LIKE. BUT I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO DO THAT
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR. MY YOU
KNOW FERNANDES. UM WHICH IS
LIKE IN IN. THE FORMULA IS WAS
JUST THERE JUST WITH THAT Z. AT
THE END OF HER LAST NAME- IT
WAS A BLESSING SO THEN I-
BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE I SAW
THE STRENGTH OF THAT AND JUST
THE BEAUTIFUL WORK AND- FOR
MEDIA THAT HAPPENS WHEN WE ARE
TOGETHER THAT WAY AND WE BUILD.
OUR OWN STORIES OF WE'RE AT THE
HOME OF OUR STORIES AND LOOKED
AROUND A LOT OF OUR STORIES
WERE BEING TOLD FOR US YOU
KNOW. AND THAT IS STOCK. BUT UP.
SORT OF A CULTURAL MONSANTO
WHEN WE CONSUME VERSIONS OF
OURSELVES. A PRODUCED BY THE
DOMINANT CULTURE THEN I GO AND
JOIN A ROOM. YOU KNOW LOOK AT
THE END BECAUSE WE SPEAK AND
SPEND BECAUSE IT'S ALL IT
TRICKLE DOWN THE FENCE- EFFECT
IN THAT WAY- I'M GONNA TELL YOU
ABOUT A FEW THINGS THAT I. JUST
YOU KNOW I THAT THAT I STARTED-
WE WROTE AND- I STARTED ALL-
BUT THE NOT. IN GHANA'S I DON'T
KNOW THE STATE OF IOWA MOST OF.
SURE INNER LET ME ASSURE
EARNERS AND HOLLYWOOD- UNTITLED
AT THE NEXT PROJECT WE CALL IT
AND- WE WROTE AN OPEN LETTER TO
HOLLYWOOD'S DEMANDING NO
STORIES ABOUT US WITHOUT US.
AND MAKING OTHER DEMANDS. WE'RE
GONNA SAY ASKS NOW SO THEY
DON'T GET SCARED BUT LIKE. WHO
IN THEIR INTO THE STUDIOS AND
SORT OF BE LIKE HEY. LET'S TAKE
THE TEMPERATURE HIGHER DOING SO
THAT MY GROUP IS EIGHTEEN OF US
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GO IN
THERE AND SORT OF LIKE. OKAY
STOP SAYING THE MAN'S. YOU KNOW
BUT LIKE ASK AND THEN- I ALSO-
WITH MY HAVE A DEAL WITH- YOU
SEE P. I STARTED AN IGNITION
LAB- AND TALENT AND CURATOR FOR
LETTING THIS AND WE- I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THEY'RE LIKE ACTUAL- THE
PROBLEM ALSO WITH SPECIALLY
WITH CREATORS AND WRITERS IS
THAT. IT'S HARD FOR US TO ENTER
THE INDUSTRY. AND IT'S HARD FOR
US TO- MOVE LEVELS SOMETIMES IT
WE GET STUCK IN AND THIS
INCUBATOR SORT OF IS GOING TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE THOSE THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS- AND I ALSO
CO FOUNDED THE WRITERS ACCESS
SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS. ARE
TRYING TO ENTER THE INDUSTRIES
ALSO THAT SCRIPT COORDINATORS
AND- WRITERS ASSISTANTS ARE THE
ENTRY LEVEL POINT BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ONE THING YOU'LL RECALL
THAT IS IN HOLLYWOOD YOU KNOW-
TO GIVE US THAT GIG SO WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO HELP WITH ENTRY
LEVEL STUFF. AND THAT'S JUST
FROM NOTICING. THAT YOU KNOW
THAT SPEAKING SPEAKING SPEND
LIKE DYNAMIC PERMEATES
THROUGHOUT THE THAT THE
INDUSTRY- I'LL STOP THEM BUT-
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR IT BUT
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO SAY. I
THINK WE WERE EXCITED TO HEAR
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT
WAS A TREMENDOUS- CASE STUDY IF
YOU WELL BUT- THAT FASCINATING.
EXPERIENCES I'M GLAD YOU'RE
THERE DOING THIS HARD WORK.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
DO THE LEAN THAT NITA A WRITER
AND CO EXECUTIVE PRODUCER ON
THE FORTHCOMING SPIN OFF OF
AMAZON'S THE BOYS. HI EVERYONE
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU GUYS SO
MUCH FOR GIVING ME THIS TIME TO
BE THE DRAW BUTTON ISSUE I AM
INSANELY PASSIONATE ABOUT
LATINO REPRESENTATION IN THE TV
WRITERS ROOM I COULD NOT HAVE
COME AFTER A MORE WONDERFUL
MORE BRILLIANT TALENT UNTIL
MISTER ROGERS HAS BEEN
TRAILBLAZING FOR US AND SO I
GIVE HER KUDOS I SENT HER LOVE-
MY NAME IS TOO LEAN AND HERE I
AM PORTER RICANS I'M NOT GOING
TO APOLOGIZE FOR TALKING FAST.
THIS IS JUST PART OF MY
CULTURAL HERITAGE SO THE
QUICKER OR ONE ONE ON ME I AM A
VERY PROUD WRITERS GUILD OF
AMERICA MEMBER AND HAVE BEEN A
WORKING TELEVISION WRITER AND
PRODUCER FOR THE PAST EIGHT
YEARS. MOSTLY I AM KNOWN FOR MY
WORK IN THE SUPERHERO SPACE IF
YOU OR YOUR KIDS HAVE WATCHED
THE FLASH ON THE CW YOU MIGHT
RECOGNIZE MY NAME. BUT WHAT I
AM MOST PROUD OF IS THAT I AM
THE CO ORGANIZER ALONG WITH MY
FELLOW TV WRITER DEANNA MENDEZ
OF A GROUP CALLED LEASE THAT
THE LEAST THAT IS A NETWORKING
GROUP FOR WORKING LATINA TV
WRITERS YOU CAN FIND US AT ARE
VERY OBVIOUS WEBSITE. LET THE A
TV WRITERS DOT COM. TNN I
LAUNCHED LITERALLY SPENT ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AGO AND USUALLY JUST
AS A BRUNCH GROUP WHERE WORKING
WITH THE NETWORK TV WRITERS
COULD GET TOGETHER AND COULD
NOT WORK AND DRINK AND VENTS
AND WHEN WE STARTED AT LEAST
THAT. THERE WERE THIRTY EIGHT
OF US THAT'S RIGHT FIVE YEARS
AGO THERE WERE LESS THAN FORTY
CREDITED LATINO TV WRITERS
WORKING ACROSS OUR ENTIRE
INDUSTRY EVERY. SINGLE ONE OF
US FIT IN ONE BACKYARD. NO SOME
THEN HAVE SEEN SOME PER. AND
THE NUMBER OF WORKING WITH YOU
KNOW WRITERS HAS QUADRUPLED.
TODAY LOVELY SPOT HAS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
MEMBERS. AND WHILE THAT IS NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH IT'S A START. SO
AS AN ORGANIZER FOR ARE SMALL
BUT MIGHTY LET THE A TV WRITER
COMMUNITY I AM VERY OFTEN ASKED
HOW CAN WE CREATE MORE
REPRESENTATION FOR LATINOS IN
TV WRITERS ROOM. ROOMS AND
THEY'RE VERY OFTEN TENDS TO BE
TO WORK THIS ONE THIS DESIRE TO
WANT TO CREATE NEW FELLOWSHIPS
AND PROGRAMS TO TRAIN ASPIRING
LATINO WRITERS. AND TO THAT I
SAY YES ABSOLUTELY DO WHAT
EVERY BIT HELPS BUT THOSE TYPES
OF PIPELINE PROGRAMS FOR ENTRY
LEVEL UNDER REPRESENTED
WRITERS. AEGS THIS TO NOW AND I
KNOW THIS BECAUSE IT'S HOW I
GOT MY START I LITERALLY WOULD
NOT BE A TV WRITER TODAY IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE NATIONAL
HISPANIC MEDIA COALITION'S
SERIES SCRIPT WRITERS
FELLOWSHIP. AND AGENCY DOT ORG
BACKSLASH WRITERS AND YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM BRENDA AND A
BIT I CANNOT SING THE PRAISES
ENOUGH OF THE AND H. M. C.
EVERY YEAR THEY FOSTER A NEW
CLASS OF ASPIRING LACK NEXT TV
WRITERS. AND IF YOU HAVE MONEY
TO GIVE THEM GIVE IT TO THEM SO
THEY CAN TRAIN EVEN MORE. IN
PART BECAUSE OF PROGRAMS LIKE
AND AGENCIES AND SIMILAR PIPE
LINE PROGRAMS N. ABC CBS AND
ELSEWHERE WE ARE SEEING THIS
HUGE INCREASE AND LATINOS WHO
ARE GETTING THEIR FOOT IN THE
DOOR. 30% OF LEVY SAYS MEMBERS
ARE STAFF WRITER LEVELS THAT
MEANS ONE THIRD OF OUR GROUP OF
WRITERS WHO HAVE ONE YEAR OF
ROOM EXPERIENCE UNDER THEIR
BELT. BUT THE PROBLEM IS LIKE
THEM YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THE
SAME WRITERS THEY'RE NOT
BREAKING THROUGH THE RANKS. AND
MOST OF ALL THEY'RE NOT BEING
PUT IN CHARGE. LAST YEAR THERE
WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE A SCRIPTED TELEVISION
SHOWS. SEVEN WERE CREATED OR CO
CREATED BY A LATINA. LATINOS
ARE 9% OF THE US POPULATION WE
ARE BARELY 1% OF TELEVISION
SHOW RUNNERS. AND THIS MATTERS
SO MUCH BECAUSE IN TV THE SHOW
RUNNER IS THE EQUIVALENT OF A
CEO. SHOWRUNNERS. WEIGH IN ON
THE HIRING OF ACTOR FIRST
THREE. AND THEY FLY. EVERY
OTHER WRITER THAT WRITERS FOR.
AS AND THE BY THOMAS. IN
TRAILED BIDA THE SINGLE BEST
WAY TO INCREASE LATINO
REPRESENTATION IN THE WRITERS
ROOM AND ON SCREEN AND EVEN ON
THE CREW IS TO PUT LATINOS IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY CAN HIRE
OTHER LET. US PUT US IN CHARGE.
NOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ONLY
THE STUDIOS AND THE NETWORKS
HAVE THE POWER TO DO BUT THERE
IS A WIDE RANGE OF WAYS THAT
THEY CAN ACCELERATE DOING IT.
THEY CAN PUT MORE LATINAS UNDER
OVERALL SPIELS WERE UNDER FIRST
LOOK DEALS GETTING FIRST ACCESS
TO ELECTING A WRITER'S ORIGINAL
IDEAS. THEY CAN OFFER MORE
BLANK SCRIPT COMMITMENT
SPECIFICALLY TO LATINOS
BASICALLY PROMISING TO BUY A TO
BE AGREED UPON STORY. THEY CAN
SIMPLY COMMIT TO TRIPLING THE
NUMBER OF LATINO CREATED
STORIES THANK BY. AND THEN
COMMITTED TO PUTTING THE
STORIES ON HERE. I KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THE STATS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE SHARING TODAY CAN BE
INCREDIBLY DISHEARTENING SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT FROM
FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE THROUGH A
LOT OF THE STUFF WE CAN AFFECT
CHANGE JUST FIVE YEARS. AND SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
STARTING THIS CONVERSATION I'M
OPTIMISTIC. FOR WHAT WE CAN DO
WITH THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. WOW
WHAT HOW HOUSE GROUP THIS IS
AWESOME- A LOT TO DIGEST BUT A
LOT OF HOPE TO AT. NEXT UP
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM TERRY
VELASQUEZ- IN AND I OUT SEE%
LOCAL SEVEN OH SIX- UNION
JOURNEYMAN HAIRSTYLIST. I'M
SORRY WE USE THE TERM
JOURNEYMAN STYLE- BUT THAT IS
THE OFFICIAL TERM WHOSE.
JOURNEY JOURNEY PERSON JOURNEY
WOMAN. WHO HAS WORKED WELL
FORTY NINE TV SHOWS AND FILMS-
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
TERRY. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
HELLO EVERYONE AND WOW WHAT AN
AMAZING GROUP OF WOMEN WE HAVE-
IT INCREDIBLE- I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE INVITATION TO APPEAR TODAY-
BUT YES I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY FOR-
FOR THIRTY YEARS OVER THIRTY
YEARS STARTING OUT AT THE LA
OPERA AND- BALLET MUSIC CENTER
AND- I'VE BEEN- CALLED. THE
DREAM AND HAIR STYLIST FOR
LOCAL SEVEN OH SIX- I'VE ALSO
BEEN WORKING WITH THOUSANDS OF
CREW MEMBERS LIKE MYSELF WHO
YOU HAVE NEVER HEARD OF BUT
WHOSE WORK. MAKES WHAT YOU SEE
ON THE SCREEN POSSIBLE AND AS A
DEPARTMENT HEAD I OVERSEE ALL
THE HAIR STYLIST ON SET. I'M A
PROUD EXAMPLE OF THE LATINO
WHO'S THE CHIEF SEVEN SUCCESS
IN MY INDUSTRY- OVER MY THIRTY
YEARS WORKING HERE IN LOS
ANGELES I HAVE SEEN A CHANGE
AND LATINO BLACK ASIAN. LBGT Q.
CREW ON THE SET AND I BELIEVE
THE HAIR AND MAKE UP LOCAL HAS
DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
EXPANDING INTO A MORE. DIVERSE
MEMBERSHIP. I'M NOT USUALLY THE
ONLY LATINA IN THEIR DEPARTMENT
HOWEVER WHERE I HAVE SEEN LESS
CHANGE IS LIKE WHICH I'M GOING
TO ECHO WHAT GREAT WOMEN BEFORE
MAY HAVE SAID. OUR THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGETHAT MEANS PRODUCERS
EXECUTIVE STUDIO HEADS SHOW
RUNNERS. THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE
HIRING AND DECIDE WHAT GETS ON
THE SCREEN LATIN WOMEN ARE
GENERALLY NOT PEOPLE IN CHARGE
WHEN IT COMES TO ABOVE THE LINE.
SOME OF THE BEARS I'VE SEEN
TIME AND TIME AGAIN ARE THE
STEREOTYPES THAT DISTORT THE
PERCEPTION OF LATINOS. RARELY
IS A LATINA SEEN AS THE
INTELLECTUAL OR THE LEADER OF
THE BIG CORPORATION OR THE TYPE
A PERSON WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
THINGS. THE STEREOTYPES
PORTRAYED IN FILM AND
TELEVISION NEEDS CHANGE. WELL
THAT'S CLEARLY NOT THE ONLY
ANSWER TO CHANGING OUR PLACE IN
AMERICA. CHANGE IN WHAT PEOPLE
SEE ON TELEVISION AND IN FILM
WILL HELP WITH REAL WORLD
CHANGE. FOR ME PERSONALLY OF
COURSE THERE ARE THE MICRO
AGGRESSIONS I DEAL WITH DAY TO
DAY. PEOPLE ASKING ME TO
TRANSLATE FOR THEIR MEXICAN
NANNY. FOR THEIR GARDENER OR
COMPLAINING ABOUT THEIR
HOUSEKEEPER OR JOKES ABOUT.
IMMIGRANTS OR A BEGINNER. BUT
THERE'S ALSO TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
STEP UP ON A RECENT SET ONE OF
THE CREW WAS COMPLAINING ABOUT
THE NOISE FROM THE CONSTRUCTION
SITE NEXT DOOR AND SAID ONE WE
JUST CALL IMMIGRATION. TELL
SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN THAT
INSTANCE THE DIRECTOR AND
MYSELF WE BOTH SPOKE UP AND
SHOT THAT COMMENT RIGHT DOWN.
THE APPROPRIATENESS WAS
ADDRESSED IN THAT MOMENT. WELL
MY YEARS IN INDUSTRY HAVE LED
ME TO BELIEVE IS THAT THE
PROBLEM OF DIVERSITY IN
HOLLYWOOD IS NOT SIX AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUALLY PUSH TO GET
A SEAT AT THE TABLE MY INDUSTRY
REFLECTS THE LARGER PROBLEM WE
FACE IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY. IN
FACT WHAT WORRIES ME IS THAT
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST
RIGHT NOW IS THAT TOO MANY
PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS DEBATE
THE NEED FOR CHANGE. IN BLACK
AND WHITE. PEOPLE NEED TO OPEN
THEIR EYES TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THAT THE NUANCED OF
DIVERSITY IS GETTING LOST. WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT PEOPLE
COME IN A RAINBOW OF COLORS. WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT DIVERSITY
CAN BE APPLIED TO AGE
DISABILITY GENDER. AND SEXUAL
PREFERENCE AS WELL. SOMETIMES
IT'S NOT SO OBVIOUS WHO SOMEONE
IS. AND WHAT I MEAN IS THAT
I'VE HAD PEOPLE WHO ASKED ME TO
HIRE SOMEONE SAY WELL THAT
PERSON'S NOT DIVERSE ENOUGH OR
WE WANT A CERTAIN TYPE OF
PERSON. BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
I ANY IDEA. THAT DIVERSITY
MIGHT BE RIGHT THERE LOOKING AT
THEM IN THE FACE. LATINAS OFTEN
GET HURT BY THIS LIMITED
ATTITUDE OFTEN FROM EXECUTIVE
SUITES I KNOW THIS. SEEN AS
REPRESENTING DIVERSITY AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL OR FOR THE CHANGE
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. WHAT KIND
OF WORLD VIEW CREATE DISK THAT
KIND OF WORLD VIEW CREATE
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID OR ANGRY WITH EACH
OTHER. THAT WILL GET US WHERE
WE NEED TO GO WE DON'T WANT TO
PIT PEOPLE AGAINST EACH OTHER
THAT WILL GET US WHERE WE WANT
TO GO. WE NEED TO RESPECT AND
EMBRACE THE NEW PEOPLE WE MUST
GET INTO THIS INDUSTRY. BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO RESPECT THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HERE. WE SET OUR
SIGHTS ON INCLUSION BOTH ON THE
SET BUT ALSO WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO GREEN LIGHT. WHAT KIND OF
SHOWS WE SEE AND WHO GETS HIRED.
THIS IS A BUSINESS THAT IS VERY
MUCH BUILT ON TRUST. TO GET
YOUNG LATINAS INTO THIS
INDUSTRY WE'RE GOING TO NEED
MORE THAN PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF
OFFERING THEM BY HAND. WE NEED
AND WANT EVERYONE TO DO IT. AND
I BELIEVE THAT MEANS WE NEED TO
MAKE CHANGES EVERYONE'S
INTEREST SOMETHING TO BE
EMBRACED AND NOT RUN FROM. THE
CHALLENGE OF CHANGES TO MAKE
EVERYONE BELIEVE IN ITS
NECESSITY AND GREATER THAT. I
WORK IN AN INDUSTRY WHERE
CHANGE HAPPENS EVERY DAY ON THE
SET AND I DO BELIEVE WE CAN GET
THERE. THANK YOU GUYS I
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHILE I'M WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
BEFORE THE NEXT PANEL THAT WAS
FABULOUS AND I'M SURE SOME OF
THE EVERYBODY HAS SOME
QUESTIONS ALL START WITH ONE
AND THEN- WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ASK. THE OTHER MEMBERS. WHAT
QUESTIONS OF ANY THEY HAVE- I
WAS STRUCK WHEN- PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
THEY'VE DEVELOPED TO HELP WITH
DIVERSITY. BUT IN A KIND OF
BROADER SENSE CAN YOU. ADDRESS
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
DIVERSITY PROGRAMS THAT STUDIOS
HAVE. OR ARE THEY WORKING WHY
OR WHY NOT WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
IMPROVE THEM IT SEEMS IT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME. THAT THE-
ARE CLEAR TO ME THAT SOME OF
THE EXAMPLES GIVEN WERE WERE
THINGS THAT YOU ALL DID
YOURSELVES TO HELP LEND A HAND
OR OR A TO BROUGHT IN- THAT THE
NETWORK BUT- WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR
VIEWS IF ANY ON THE DIVERSITY
PROGRAMS AT THE STUDIOS HAVE.
ANY OF. I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK TO
MY EXPERIENCE I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT AGENCY
FELLOWSHIP BUT ALSO TO DO N. B.
C.'S WRITERS ON THE VERGE WHICH
IS A IN STUDIO- STUDIO
INITIATIVE AT NBC AND I THINK
THEY'RE FANTASTIC BUT THEIR
NUMBERS OF WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
YEAH IT'S YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GETTING TWO THOUSAND THREE
THOUSAND APPLICANTS EACH YEAR
AND GREW THEIR FORTUNATE IF
THEY HAVE ONE LEFT IN- IN THAT
IN EACH CLASS EACH YEAR. AND
IT'S- I AM AND I KNOW THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THE REAL PROBLEM WITH
THESE INITIATIVES. WITHIN THE
STUDIO SYSTEM IS THAT THERE ARE
GREAT TO GET YOU IN THE DOOR
BUT THEN THEY DO NOT HELP YOU
TO GET THE SECOND JOB. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SEEING IN OUR
OF NETWORKING GROUP THAT 30% OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE OUR- STAFF
WRITER LEVEL. IT'S BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET HIRED AS STORY
EDITORS WHICH IS THE SECOND
TIER UP. WHICH IS LITERALLY
DOUBLE THE PAY SO IF THEY CAN
COME FOR FREE OR CHEAP THEIR
STUDIO SYSTEM THEN THEY'RE
GETTING WORK BUT THEN WHEN. IT
REQUIRES ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOU
KNOW COME OUT OF A TRUE BUDGET.
THERE THE- THE STEP UP FOR THAT
DIVERSITY IS TO STOP THEIR
WE'RE NOT SEEING IT TO THE SAME
EXTENT- I KNOW I HAVE I YOU
KNOW I HAVE CONTACTS AT THESE.
DIFFERENT EQUITY YOU KNOW.
EXECUTIVES I KNOW THAT THEY
KNOW THIS IS A PROBLEM IT'S NOT
THE WORKING TOWARDS. BUT IT'S
STILL AN ISSUE. THANK YOUNG.
CAME THROUGH- A DIFFERENT
ASPECT I GUESS IT WAS A
DIVERSITY HIRE- AND
HISTORICALLY A LOT OF PEOPLE. I
MET HAD TO REPEAT BECAUSE I'M
AS- THESE DIVERSITY HIRES THEY
THEY HIRE YOU FOR LIKE THE
TWENTY BASIC WEEKS. AND THEN.
THEY LET YOU GO AND THEN THE
NEXT YEAR THEY START WITH A NEW
DIVERSITY HIGHER SO THAT THEY
DON'T SO IT DOESN'T COST HIM
ANYTHING BUT- EIGHT. SOMETIMES
YOU KNOW. I KNOW PEOPLE REPEAT
IT LIKE FIVE TIMES AND IT'S A-
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT'S A GOOD
PROGRAM I WOULD NOT HAVE
GOTTEN. IN IF IT HADN'T BEEN
FOR BUT THEY THERE'S NO LIKE-
SUPERVISION OF IT. ESPECIALLY
CULTURALLY OF HOW IT'S BEING
ENFORCED IN THE ROOM. FOR
EXAMPLE ALL OF THIS YOU KNOW
HOW I WAS. TALKED ABOUT OR
TALKED TO IN THE END THAT
HAPPENS ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THERE THERE ARE SOME GOOD
PROGRAMS AND THAT THAT ARE.
GOOD WELL INTENTIONED BUT THEN
IN PRACTICE IT'S- LIKE YOU SAID
LIKE YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA SAID
LIKE SOMETIMES LIKE. IT THERE
THEY WORK AS AN ENTRY BUT BUT
THAT THAT THAT THERE'S A BLOCK
YOU KNOW THERE'S A BLOCK THERE-
WE OF THE PROGRAMS THAT I AM-
MY STUDIO BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE TO AT SOME CHANGE A
LITTLE BIT AND LIKE AND- AND DO
ESPECIALLY IN THIS MOMENT AND
AFTER THE SUMMER RECKONING WITH
TO SHAME A LITTLE BIT BE LIKE.
BECAUSE WE- UNFORTUNATELY AND
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO TALK TO
YOU- I'M A CRISTINA I WHITE WE
NEED THE NUMBERS TO GO IN THERE
AND BE LIKE THIS IS HOW MUCH
WE'RE CONSUMING AS LIKE THE
NEST. THIS IS HOW MUCH WE'RE WE
DON'T. HAVE ACTUAL NUMBERS FOR
TV. THE NUMBERS RELEASED ACTOR
AND STUFF BUT FOR CREATORS AND
WRITERS WE ACTUALLY NEED THAT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. I WENT INTO
MY STUDIO S. AT LIKE OF THEM
WITH A MORAL IMPERATIVE LIKE.
YOU SHOULD IT IS THE RIGHT
THING BUT I DON'T HAVE NUMBERS
TO BACK MEET YOU KNOW. BUT
BECAUSE THE SUMMER RECKONING
WAS. I WHAT I HAVE THAT YOU
KNOW. TO- THAT WE WE'RE I'M
WE'RE HAVING AN INCUBATOR
PROGRAM THAT. IS GOING TO. PAY
THE FIVE. UP PARTICIPANTS THE
EIGHTY SIX K. AS A BLIND SCRIPT
DEAL BASICALLY- FOR EACH ONE
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER THING
LIKE SOMETIMES WE GET IN THERE.
AND I IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
THEY DON'T PAY. YOU IT'S REALLY
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT SO THAT
LIKE THAT BUT THIS MEANS.
RESPECT FOR THE VOICE YOU KNOW-
AND WE JUST HAVE TO GET LIKE.
RESPECTFUL VOICES MONEY BECAUSE
THAT THAT'S IT IT'S LIKE HOW E
CAN'T EAT LIKE SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW LIKE THIS INTO- I KNOW
BALLING LIST. IS THERE THESE
OF. THE PROGRAM. THERE ARE
VOLUNTEERS WHEN YOU FIRST
INSURANCE SORRY- THIS INTER
PROGRAM SOMETIMES WE CAN
AFFORD- WE DON'T HAVE LIKE.
PARENTS THAT. THAT CAN PAY FOR
AS WELL WE HAVE THAT YEAR OF
INTERNSHIP YOU KNOW SO LIKE IT-
AND REYES I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING BUT I AM SO EXCITED TO
BE HERE. OKAY I'LL MEET. THIS
IS GREAT. SAYS THAT I'M WELL
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU ALL FOR
SUCH WONDERFUL REMARKS AN
INSIGHT INTO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE INDUSTRY AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING A PART OF PAVING THIS
ROAD AND KEEP IT ON YOUR MIND
ON YOUR MINDS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF YOUR MIND NOT WE ALL STAND
ON THE SHOULDERS OF GIANTS
SOMEONE I THINK THAT'S CAN
STAND ON OTHER LOOKING AT
SHOULDERS IT'S EVEN MORE VITAL
AND IMPORTANT AND YOU'RE DOING
THAT SO THANK YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO I'M AT THOMAS NEAR AYE AYE
AYE TO IMPORT AGAIN SO CONTENT
TO TALK FAST AND I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
AND BRING UP HENRY DORROUGH WHO
PASSED AWAY- IN MARCH AND WAS
REALLY A TRAILBLAZER IN THE
INDUSTRY HELPING TO FOUND THE
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD- ETHNIC
COMMITTEE- AND I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION HAD HIM BUT I ALSO WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES. ON MY
DISTRICT THE SENATE CREDO
GROWING PRODUCTION INDUSTRY- I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FRONT OF
THIS DILEMMA WE'RE FACING WHICH
IS THE WORK FORCE AND. ACCESS
TO S. N. AND- I PROVIDING US.
WORK AND- OVER THE PAST DECADE
WE'VE SEEN THIS PUSH FOR STEAM
EDUCATION NOT JUST STEM. BUT
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY. ENGINEERING
ARTS AND MUSIC HOW CAN WE-
SUPPORT THE YOUNGER GENERATIONS
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE. TO
REALLY BE EQUIPPED WITH THE
SKILLS TO BE COMPETITIVE IN THE
INDUSTRY. AND HOW DID YOU GET
INTO THE INDUSTRY WHAT DID YOU
DO WHAT WOULD YOU TELL. OTHER
YOUNG LATINO WOMEN WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR A PLACE IN THIS
INDUSTRY WHETHER IT'S WRITING.
WHETHER IT'S A SET BUILDING
PAINTING SEAMSTRESS- BEING A- A
CATERER YOU KNOW WHAT CAN THEY
DO NOW. AND HOW CAN WE BE
SUPPORTIVE. THANKS I MEAN I
THINK- OH SORRY I JUST WANTED
TO I JUST WANT TO CHIME IN AND
THEN- EVERYONE ELSE ON THE
PANEL TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES BUT I JUST WANTED
TO PLUG- BUT YOU SONORA PROJECT
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT IS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND- IT'S-
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN OTHER
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD
ACTUALLY BUT- WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IT'S RUN BY
THE LATINO FILM INSTITUTE AND
IT'S- IS PART OF THE
CURRICULUM. THAT IS- FOR-
FOURTH AND FIFTH GRADERS AND
THEN SOME STUDENTS IN HIGH
SCHOOL SO WHAT- WHAT IT IS THAT
THAT THE STUDENTS ARE TRAINED-
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
TO THE END OF THE YEAR TO
CREATE THEIR OWN TOWN SO THEY
BECOME FILMMAKERS AND- WHAT IT
HAS HELPED IS- JUST REALLY HELP
WITH THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SKILLS AND- JUST MADE THEM MORE
CONFIDENCE BUT ALSO WHAT THE-
YOU KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS IT'S OPENED THEIR EYES
TO THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
AND ZERO BY THE TIME THAT THEY
ARE DONE WITH ON THE PROGRAM
THEY CREATED A SHORT FILM THAT
THEY END UP SHOWING AT THE
LATINO FILM INSTITUTES-
FESTIVAL LET LEAVE AND SO IT'S
JUST A WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE IT HELPS THEM- JUST
WITH THEIR YOU KNOW SELF ESTEEM
AND TO DO WELL IN SCHOOL BUT
THEN ALSO- IT JUST SHOWS THEM
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE BECOMING
A FILMMAKER IS NOT SOME
ABSTRACT IDEA AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS OUT OF THEIR
REACH AND SO. I JUST WANTED TO
PLUG THAT THAT- PROGRAM AND YOU
KNOW THAT PROGRAM- COULD BE AT
EVERY SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA IT
JUST. NEEDS MORE FUNDING.
THANKS THANKS A TERRY WAS GOING.
JUMP INTO. YES I ACTUALLY GOING
TO ECHO- THE SAME IDEA- IN IN
EDUCATION AND- ARTS BASED
EDUCATION AND INTRODUCING KIDS
AT THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEVEL
OF MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL HAT THESE KINDS OF JOBS
EXIST AND- I GOT INTO THIS
BUSINESS REALLY REALLY YOUNG
AND REALLY EARLY AND GOT A HAND
OUT BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY THIS
IS A BUSINESS WHERE. YOU DON'T
HEY WHERE CAN I PUT MY
APPLICATION IS SOMEONE REALLY
HAS YOU HAVE TO BE INVITED YOU
KNOW ONE- THERE'S NO PLACE TO
SIGN UP FOR IT SOMEBODY HAS TO
BRING YOU IN AND SOMEBODY
BROUGHT ME IN. AND I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO DO TO MENTOR SHIPS-
OPEN PANDEMIC I WAS INVITED TO
A NEW YORK CITY BASED TASK
FORCE WHERE I'M INSURED- A
WOMAN AND I MENTOR IT SOMEONE
HERE IN LOS ANGELES AS WELL TO.
TRYING TO GET INTO MY INDUSTRY
WHAT WOULD STEPS I TOOK- AND I
THINK THAT. MENTORSHIPS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND IF WE
COULD PUT THAT. CONNECTION WITH
IT'S COMING OUT OF COLLEGE OR
KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL WHO MAYBE
WANT TO WORK BELOW THE LINE OR
ABOUT THE LINE- TO LET THEM
KNOW THAT THESE JOBS EVEN EXIST
YOU KNOW I NEVER I GREW UP IN
LA AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW MY JOB
EXISTED. AND AND THE THIRD THE
GOOD PAYING JOBS THE UNION JOBS
ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS AND WE
NEED TO LET WE NEED TO BRIDGE
THAT. IN IN EDUCATION. AND THE
WORKPLACE SO WHETHER THAT'S
WITH MENTORSHIPS INTERNSHIPS-
YOU KNOW MAKING OUR PRESENCE
KNOWN AND YOU KNOW AND THE ARTS
OF REALLY SEPARATE OVER THE
YEARS AND PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
I THINK IT'S BEGINS THERE WE
REALLY NEED TO GET BACK TO.
ARTS BASED CURRICULUMS. I FEEL
REALLY STRONGLY THAT. THAT IS
PROBABLY OUR WEAKEST LINK IS
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION- HAS CUT
ALL THE ARTS. AND FUNDING FOR
THE ARTS. SO I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT PLACE TO START THAT'S A
GREAT DIRECTIVE PRESS PRESSURE
AT WENDY DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION I THANK YOU- I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR THE EXPERIENCES OF
GETTING INTO THE WRITERS ROOM
SO YOU KNOW IT IT'S- THE
CHALLENGE RIGHT TO EVEN BECOME
THIS THE STEPS THAT YOU NEED TO
TAKE TO EVEN BECOME A SHOW
RUNNER. BEGINS TO EVEN GETTING
ACCESS TO THE INTERNSHIP TO GET
INTO THE WRITERS ROOM CAN YOU
SHARE SOME OF THOSE THOSE
CHALLENGES WHAT YOU SEEN WITH
THOSE EXPERIENCES HAVE BEEN I
MANY MANY MOONS AGO IN A PAST
LIFE- WAS IN A WRITERS ROOM AND
I JUST FOUND THAT THE- THE
BROMANCE AND THE- YOU KNOW
THOSE. IT'S JUST IT'S VERY HARD
FOR WOMEN AND VERY HARD FOR
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN OF COLOR AND
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET INTO THOSE
ROOMS. WHERE- OTHER- WRITERS
ARE CREATING AND MAKING
DECISIONS ON WHAT THE STORIES
ARE LATINOS AND LATINAS SHOULD
LOOK LIKE AND I'M I AM CURIOUS
WHAT THE EXPERIENCES HAVE BEEN.
FOUR PANELISTS. WELL I'M SURE
IT WAS GOING TO SAY SOMETHING-
I. JUST FROM IT'S A PRETTY
BECAUSE NOW THERE'S MORE OF US
LIKE TO LINA SAID RIGHT LIKE
THERE'S- MORE OF A STRETCH. THE
THERE'S THE OPTION OF
RESENTMENT THAT I KEEP HEARING
ESPECIALLY FROM STRAIGHT A'S
STRAIGHT CIS WHITE MALES ARE
LIKE SLOW THEY'RE COMING FOR
OUR JOBS IT IS SO PRESENT IT IS
AND YOU KNOW WHO'S PERPETUATING
THE ABOUT THE AGENTS THERE LIKE
ARE YOU CAN GET THAT JOB IS IT
WHEN DIVERSE WHICH I HATE THE
TERM DIVERSITY HIGHER IT'S-
IT'S UNDER BROWN USED TERM YOU
CAN HAVE ONE THING TO BE
DIVERSE RIGHT BUT LIKE IT'S
COLD BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
SAY THAT THE MAN OR WHATEVER
YOU KNOW. BUT BUT I DO FEEL
LIKE WE ARE ENTERING BUT THEN
WE ARE MET WITH A LOT OF ROOM.
LIKE MY AGGRESSIONS BUT EVEN TO
ENTER BECAUSE I THINK THAT WAS
THE QUESTION RIGHT. IT IS NOT
ONE OF THOSE LIKE I CAN APPLY
FOR THE JOB SITUATION YOU HAVE
TO. HAVE CAUGHT FIRE SOMEHOW SO
WHAT I NEED LIKE SO EITHER
YOU'RE A PILOT YOU WROTE OR- OF
WEB SERIES YOU'RE YOU YOU
CREATED OR A PLATE THAT WHICH
WAS HOW I ENTERED. CATCHES
FIRE. AND THEN SOME EVEN IF
YOU'RE AND YOU MIGHT BE
ASSISTING YOU EVERY AND THEN
YOU MIGHT GET A MANAGER YOU
MIGHT GET. AN AGENT THE TEN
CENTS TO SUBMIT YOU FOR JOBS I
MEAN THE STEPS TO GET. INTO A
WRITER FROM ARE SO MANY YOU
HAVE YOU HAVE TO GET
REPRESENTATION YOU CAN'T JUST-
GET INTERVIEW OR WHATEVER FOR
IT FOR A FOR OUR WRITERS ROOM
POSITION. WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION AND THEN AND
THEN YOU'RE COMPETING YOU KNOW
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET IN LIKE
WE TOLD YOU LIKE- SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T LET YOU REPEAT
ITSELF SO IT'S- I'M A LITTLE.
I'M SURE YOU- HAVE MORE INSIGHT
ON THAT I'VE BEEN I'VE SAT OUT
THE- COULD NOT NOT LIKE I'M
JUST WRITING- PILOTS AND I KNOW
THAT NOW THERE'S LIKE. SHORTER
ROOMS SO LIKE- TITLES AND
LEVELS ARE NOT- AS RHYS. BACK
DID YOU DO IT LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE TO REPEAT THEM BUT
IT'S REALLY HARD TO. ENTER I-
TO GET IN BUT I DO HAVE TO SEE
THE TALENT IS OUT THERE NOT
JUST. FROM OUR BRANCH GROUP I
LIKE I HAVE FIVE HUNDRED RIGHT
WE- THE LET ME HIGHER LET THE
NEXT SECULAR FOR MY COMPANY-
HIGHLINE. AND SHE READS LIKE
FIVE SCRIPTS A DAY AND WE ARE
OUT THERE LIKE THE TALENT IS
OUT THERE IT'S JUST. A MATTER
OF. GETTING IN AND GETTING THAT
SUPPORT- YEAH AND- TO CARRY
THAT FORWARD. BUT WHENEVER I
MEET WITH THE SPY RING WRITERS
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO THIS
IT'S NOT THERE'S A TRACK THAT I
CAN SAY DO A. B. C. D. AND E.
AND THEN YOU WILL BECOME A
WRITER BECAUSE THAT IS EVERY
PERSON'S PATH IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT AND OFTENTIMES BERRY
ARBITRARY AND HAS SO MUCH TO DO
WITH A LOT- AND THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE I REFER PEOPLE
LIKE YOU KNOW I OFTENTIMES TELL
SPARRING WRITERS LIKE GO TO
ANYTIME SEIZE WEBSITE SUBMIT TO
THEIR- TV WRITING FELLOWSHIP
THAT'S- SUCH A FANTASTIC
OPPORTUNITY TO. BEGIN
NETWORKING IF YOU DON'T ALREADY
HAVE CONTACTS- THE TELEVISION
ACADEMY GOING ACTIVE WITH THEY
ALSO HAVE A GREAT INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM I HIGHLY RECOMMEND
STUDENTS APPLY THEIR PEOPLE WHO
ARE SPIERINGS- BUT SO MUCH OF
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE TO DO TO
BREAK INTO THIS INDUSTRY IS
WORK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO.
ALONE IN YOUR ROOM AND THAT IS
OFTENTIMES THE STRUGGLE OF THE
WRITER IS SITTING IN FRONT OF
YOUR COMPUTER BEING LIKE I'M
GOING TO WRITE THE SCRIPT AND
PRAY AND HOPE THAT AT SOME
POINT IT WILL GET INTO THE
HANDS OF CIRCLING THROUGH
CONTACTS AND GET A CREATE
WHETHER THAT'S ON THE ON
TWITTER OR BY CREATING CONTENT
ON TICK TOCK OR BY LAUNCHING MY
WEB SERIES ON YOUTUBE- AND SO I
JUST. REALLY ENCOURAGE YOUNGER
GENERATIONS TO CREATE AND TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
OTHER PEOPLE AROUND YOU AND TO
NOT BE AFRAID TO ASK FOR WHAT
YOU WANT IF YOU WANT TO GET
INTO A WRITERS ROOM ASK
EVERYONE AROUND YOU DO YOU KNOW
ANYONE WHO WORKS ON A SAT DO
YOU KNOW ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE
DISTANTLY CONNECTED TO A WRITER
CAN I HAVE A COFFEE WITH YOU
CAN I GET CAN I. GET YOU KNOW
PICK YOUR BRAIN CAN I GET
GUIDANCE AND INFORMATION
BECAUSE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS ARE
SO ESSENTIAL TO SUCCESS IN OUR
INDUSTRY I THINK THAT'S WHAT ON
THE AND I AND OTHER LATINOS
HAVE CREATED THESE GROUPS FOR
OURSELVES IS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF LOS
ALL LOCKING. ARMS AND HELPING
TO DRAG EACH OTHER UP. PAN WE
HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE QUESTION
I KNOW- MONEY LANA HAD A-
QUESTION. IN THE CHAT MEDINA.
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIR- I WAS
CURIOUS AS TO. WHAT THE SPANISH
LANGUAGE NETWORKS. AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. HOW IS-THAT CONNECTED- WHAT'S THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. ALL THE
FROM THE EXECUTIVES EVERYTHING
IN THAT WORLD TO OUR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY ARE THERE DIRECT
CONNECTIONS OR IS IT LIKE TO
DUMP CLEARLY DIFFERENT WORLDS
ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES OR NOT.
THERE THERE'S A BIT OF A
DISCONNECT BECAUSE- THAT A LOT
OF THOSE PRODUCTIONS ARE
SOURCED IN THE MAKING GO THIS
WAY LYING COLUMBIA AND SO AND
THEN THEY'RE IMPORTED- SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM DON'T I
MEAN IT THE ACTORS DO WORK HERE
AND THE MAKE OF IT IT'S A
DIFFERENT IT'S A DIFFERENT
LANE. NO WAY- AND. A VERY VERY
LIKE SUPPORTED AND WATCHED BUT
IT'S A DIFFERENT TYPE OF LET
LET THEME THERE WERE AFTER LIKE
A NON SPANISH SPEAKERS SOMETIME
I MEAN NOT REALLY I'M AFTER
EVERY LETTING OUR YOU KNOW BUT-
YOU KNOW I'M NOT BOTHERED WHEN
YOU SEE ON AND SHE WILL NEVER
WTCH MY SHOW I MEAN SHE SHOULD
NEVR WATCH MYSELF BECAUSE
SHOULD BE LIKE. NIEMIEC GAS IS.
SO BUT BUT BUT IT IT- WE'RE
TRYING TO TAKE UP SPACE AS
AMERICAN AT THE MISS YOU KNOW
LIKE LIKE. BECAUSE THAT IT'S A
IT'S A LINK TO LATIN AMERICA
AND IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND
THAT THAT'S ALSO HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY WAY TO RELEGATE US
AND SORT OF DISMISS US.
OPPOSITE THEY HAVE A NEW REASON
THEY HAVE THE LIMóN THAT YOU
KNOW. AND THE PRODUCTION SO
THAT THEY DON'T GET PAID
SOMETIMES ARE NINE UNION LIKE
IT'S A WHOLE MESS OVER THERE.
WE WANT TO TAKE UP SPACE LIKE
AMERICANS EVEN THOUGH I'M- NOT
AMERICAN I'M STILL HAVE A GREEN
CARD. I WOULD MAKE. BUT GET
RIGHT BECAUSE I'M MEXICAN RIGHT
WE'RE ALL AMERICANS BUT LIKE I
WANT WE WANT TO TAKE A SPACE
LIKE THAT AND THAT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE TEMPERATURES UNION
SHOWS AND MOSTLY IN ENGLISH
ALTHOUGH NOW IT'S KEEPS GETTING
MESSIER INTERNATIONAL BUT BUT
ANYWAY I LET YOU LET ME KNOW-
SIX. I'VE BEEN SAYING REALLY
INTERESTING THING WHERE-
COMPANIES THAT ARE BASED LIKE
IN MEXICO ARE ASKING FOR. YOU
KNOW LIKE LATINO WRITERS IN THE
STATES AND THERE'S A- YOU DON'T
EVEN NEED TO SPEAK SPANISH WE
JUST WANT YOU TO WRITE AND THEN
WILL TRANSLATE IT AND THEN
WE'LL SHIP IT BACK TO THE
STATES. SO THERE HAS BEEN A
REALLY INTERESTING BACK AND
FORTH IT'S HAPPENING BUT THAT'S
THAT'S A VERY MUCH BECAUSE OF
THE INTERNET BECAUSE THE
STREAMERS. BECAUSE OF THE GREAT
OUT CONTENT THAT'S BEING
CREATED INTERNATIONALLY THAT
YOU'RE SEEING ON PLACES LIKE
NETFLIX- SO THERE'S A KIND OF
BLURRING OF THE LINES- WHICH
IS. FANTASTIC BECAUSE HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL ALLOW YOU KNOW
WRITERS WHO ARE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE THOSE
CREDITS TO BE ABLE TO CROSS
OVER. AND TO MOVE BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN THE TWO SPACES.
AND ALSO THAT THE CONCERN IS
WITH- WITH STREAMERS IS THAT
THE- INTERNAL YOU KNOW HAVING
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAMMING LIKE
EVERYONE SAID IS GREAT BUT THEN
THEY JUST SAY WELL WE HAVE WE
HAVE THE DIVERSITY HERE SO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THESE- PEOPLE FROM
SPAIN AND SO YOU KNOW IN OUR
STUDY WE DON'T- CONSIDER PEOPLE
FROM SPAIN AS LATINOS BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT DOESN'T FALL UNDER
THE DEFINITION RIGHT SO THERE.
SO WE'RE NOT IN OUR CITY WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT HISPANIC SO WE
ARE SPECIFIC TO THE TALKING
ABOUT LATIN ACTS REPRESENTATION
AND SO THAT YOU KNOW THE
CONCERN IS THAT- THE COMPANIES
CAN SAY THIS YEAR'S GONNA SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS A
SPANISH. SPEAKING CONTENT OF
SPANISH LANGUAGE CONTENT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT SHOULD SATISFY
YOU BUT LIKE WHAT- I YOU KNOW
EVERYONE ON THE PANEL SAYING IS
TAT WE HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC
EXPERIENCE HERE AS U. S. LEVINE
ALSO RIGHT SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE BORN HERE TO BE CONSIDERED A
U. S. LATINO OR LATIN NEXT-
PERSON YOU JUST HAVE TO BE
LIVING HERE AND SO- WE WANT
THOSE STORIES TO BE TOLD WE
WANT. TO HAVE THOSE SHOWS THAT
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE. OF LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES. THANK YOU THAT
THIS HAS BEEN FANTASTIC- I I'M
GONNA MAKE AN ADMISSION RIGHT
HERE AND MY DAUGHTER OKAY KILL
ME BUT THIS THIS- THIS P.
SEVENTEEN LATINAS WAS NOT MY
IDEA IT WAS IT WAS WENDY
CARILLO WAS IDEA- BECAUSE I I'M
A FORMER UNION ORGANIZER I WAS
REALLY FOCUSED THE AND A LAWYER
SO I'M I'M FOCUSING ON. YOU
KNOW LOW WAGE JOBS AND LETTING
US INTO LAW IT WHEN HE'S LIKE
OH WE HAVE TO DO HOLLYWOOD AND
WE DID AND I'M EMBARRASSED TO
SAY SO MY DAUGHTER WHO I LOVE
IS IT YOU KNOW AT A PA IT AT-
NETFLIX AND SO SHE'S ACTUALLY
WATCHING SHE'S LIKE THIS IS
YOUR BEST ONE YET SO. I'M YOU
GUYS SHE SHE ACTUALLY YOU
APPRECIATE THIS I IF YOU IF I
DIDN'T HEAR PRECISELY AS SHE
GOES I FEEL A LITTLE LESS CRAZY
NOW SO- YOU PROVIDED THAT FOUR
ONE LET ME KNOW WHO'S TRYING TO
GET IN THE INDUSTRY SO IT'S
WELL KNOW THAT. I THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH IF YOU WANT TO STAY ON
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO PANEL TO.
IT AND BRING THEM TO YOU YOU
MAY WANT TO ADD ADDITIONAL I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ADD YOU AND
WHEN WE GO BACK TO- COMMENTS
BUT WITH THAT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON. TO HEAR FROM NANCY REYES
STONE WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA FILM
AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY NANCY. HELLO HI
WELL HEAR ME YES ALL RIGHT
GREAT THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK ON THIS PANEL I'M JUST
GONNA GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THE FILM
COMMISSION AND TELL YOU ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER. THE FOUNDATION
ENHANCES CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS
A LEADER IN THE MOTION PICTURE
TELEVISION COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY IT SUPPORTS
PROJECTS OF ALL SIZES AND
BUDGETS AND FOCUSES ON
ACTIVITIES THAT STIMULATE AND
PRESERVE PRODUCTION JOBS
SPENDING TAX REVENUES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA FILM
AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM'S MISSION IS TO
INCREASE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN CALIFORNIA. Y CREATING JOBS
THROUGH THE ALLOCATION OF TAX
CREDITS FOR PROJECTS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE LEAVE THE STATE. TAX
CREDITS ARE ALLOCATED MAINLY
FOR THE LOW THE LINE JOBS
BASICALLY JOBS- NOT ABOVE THE
LINE JOBS. THE ORIGINAL TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE. FIVE
PROGRAM THAT WAS FOLLOWED BY A
PROGRAM TO PLANO IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND PROGRAM THREE POINT
ALLEN TWENTY NINETEEN. AS OF
MARCH OF THIS YEAR THE CSE HAS
ALLOCATED A TOTAL OF TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
CREDITS. TO FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO PROJECTS WHICH ARE
ON TRACK TO SPEND ALMOST
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE. I DON'T FLY A HUNDRED
AND. FORTY SIX THOUSAND CAST
AND CREW. IN A TO PROMOTING ARE
I CAN DEVELOPMENT THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM INCLUDES A
CAREER READINESS REQUIREMENT
THAT INVEST IN OUR FILMMAKERS
ARTISTS AND TECHNICIANS OF
TOMORROW. TAX CREDIT PROJECTS
AND PROGRAMS TWO POINT NO
HIGHER THAN A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE. INTERNS PAID
INTERNS TOTALING THIRTY
THOUSAND INTERNSHIP HOURS IN
ADDITION THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT STUDENTS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN PROFESSIONAL
SKILLS CHORES. WELL THIRTY SIX
FACULTY MEMBERS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN EXTERNSHIPS AND
IN CLASSROOM WORKSHOPS AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING STATEWIDE
WITH HIGH SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CAREER BASED
LEARNING PROGRAMS WITH A VERY
DIVERSE GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS TO
EXPOSE THEM TO THE DIFFERENT
JOBS. THAT EXIST IN THE FILM
BUSINESS. AND I WAS HAVING SHOW
YOU SLICE DAY QUITE WORK OUT
BUT WHAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
SLIDESHOW WERE PHOTOS OF SOME
OF THESE PARTICIPANTS WE HAD
STUDENTS FROM CRENSHAW HIGH
SCHOOL WHO I WORK WITH DIRECTOR
AVA DUVERNAY WHILE SHE WAS
FILMINGA WRINKLE IN TIME
THERE. WE HAD STUDENTS FROM L.
A. COUNTY HIGH SCHOOL ON THE
SIDE OF A SERIES CALLED GOOD
TROUBLE. WE HAD- PARTICIPANTS
FROM VENICE ARTS FABULOUS
CAREER BASED LEARNING PROGRAM
IN VENICE CALIFORNIA DOING A
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS TOUR ON THE
SET OF THE SHOW TIME SERIES-
AND DORSEY HIGH SCHOOLS FILM
AND ANIMATION CLASS ON THE SIDE
OF REACH AND THAT'S JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES. OF THE HUNDREDS OF
HOURS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
OFFER TO STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO THE FILM
INDUSTRY. CAREER READINESS
REQUIRED AND HAS ALSO EARNED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM OUR TAX
CREDIT SHOWS WHICH ARE GOING
TOWARD PAID INTERNSHIPS FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS THROUGH THE
FOUNDATION. FOR TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF ARTS
MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
PROGRAMS. A PORTION OF THOSE
FUNDS ALSO PROVIDED
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR UNDERSERVED
YOUTH TO ATTEND THE CALIFORNIA
SUMMER SCHOOL. FOR THE ARTS HE
SAID. I WAS GONNA SHOW YOU WHAT
OF YOUR THAT WHO IS- AMERICAN.
WHO NEVER DURING SHE COULD TO
CALL. SHE FELT IT WASN'T. TO
PICTURE EVER GOING TO UP TO A
LOT EDUCATION. AS A RESULT OF
RECEIVING A CEASE A SCHOLARSHIP
FROM OUR CAREER READING US
FUNDS SHE WAS ABLE TO SPEND
TIME ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS
ATTENDED A COLLEGE GAVE. APPLY
TO COLLEGE AND NOW SHE'S THE
FIRST WOMAN IN THE FIRST PERSON
IN HER FAMILY TO EVER GO TO
COLLEGE SO SHE IS JUST ONE OF
MANY SUCCESS STORIES THAT WE
HAD A CAREER READINESS.
PARTICIPANTS WERE GONE ON TOOK
TO COLLEGE TO CAREERS IN THE
INDUSTRY SO IT'S VERY EXCITING
TO SEE THE PROGRESS THAT- THESE
STUDENTS HAVE MADE ONCE THEY
REALIZED. WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES. WERE IN THIS
BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT POINT OH
NOW INCLUDE A MORE FIVE
TRAINING PRO FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THESE INDIVIDUALS
WORK WITH OUR TRAINING
PROVIDERS TO OBTAIN THE SKILLS
NECESSARY TO COMPETE AND THRIVE
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS.
SO FAR WE'VE HAD FORTY ONE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE CONTRIBUTED
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THIS PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM'S FIRST PHASE INCLUDES
TEACHING LIFE SKILLS FOLLOWED
BY TECHNICAL TRAINING FOR
CAREERS IN THE INDUSTRY.
PARTICIPANTS ARE THEN MATCHED
WITH MENTORS IN THEIR FIELD AND
THIS KIND OF SPEAKS TO WHAT I
HEARD EARLIER A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE KIND OF GETTING OPPORTUNITY
AND THEN THEY'RE KIND OF. THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S
THERE TO SUPPORT THEM ALONG THE
WAY AND THIS PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE MENTORS IN THE FIELD
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
INTERESTED IN SO THEY CAN HELP
AND SUPPORT THEM PROVIDE
CONNECTIONS TO HELP THEM REALLY
GET. GOOD JOBS AND START A
CAREER IN THE INDUSTRY. ONCE
THEY COMPLETE THEIR LIFE SKILLS
EDUCATION. TRAINING AND THEY
WORK ON SOME PROJECTS. PAGE
SOME PROJECTS THEY WILL BECOME
ELIGIBLE. TO BECOME UNION
MEMBERS- ONE THING THAT I
WANTED TO ALSO SHOW YOU- WAS A
VIDEO OF- WELL ACTUALLY I DID
TALK ABOUT THAT SO WHEN HE GOT-
LET'S TALK ABOUT MATHIS WORKS
MANIFEST WORKS IS ONE OF OUR
PILOTS SKILLS PROGRAM TRAINING
PROVIDERS. THEIR CLIENTS
IDENTIFY AS 44% LATINO OR
HISPANIC 31% BLACK AND 14%
WHITE WITH THE REST IDENTIFYING
AS OTHER ETHNICITIES. THIS YEAR
MANIFEST WORKS HOLD UP WITH THE
AYE ACTUALLY SOUND LOCAL SIX
NINETY FIVE THE PLACE
INDIVIDUALS INTO A SOUND
DEPARTMENT TRAINING. OVER SIXTY
FIVE CURRENTLY HAS TWENTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR SOUND
VIDEO TRAINING PROGRAM AND I TO
THEIR GROUP. EIGHT OUR LATIN
ACTS AND THREE ARE LATINA. SO I
REACHED OUT TO THE THREE WOMEN
THE THREE LATINAS FLU SHOT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS- TO WORK
WITHIN SOUND APARTMENTS ON FILM
SETS. GUINNESS JULIANA AND YOU
SELL AND THEY TOLD ME ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES ALL OF THEM
EXPRESSED THEIR DESIRE TO BREAK
INTO FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTIONS AND ALTHOUGH THEY
ALL HAVE PRODUCTION EXPERIENCE
THEY FOUND THEMSELVES WORKING
LOW PAYING. NINE UNIONS THOUGH
JOBS OR ANY TYPE OF JOB THEY
COULD FIND TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES. THEY ALL EXPRESSED
GRATITUDE FOR BEING ABLE TO GET
INTO THIS TRAINING PROGRAM AND
HAVE ACCESS TO MENTORS AND
OTHER RESOURCES. YES SPOKE FOR
THE GROUP WHEN SHE SAID THAT
THE EXPERIENCE PROVIDED THE
PROFESSIONAL ATMOSPHERE INCOME
AND TRAINING THAT SHE REALLY
NEEDED. YES SELL ADDED I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS PROGRAM THAT
HELPS PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE AN
EASY WAY YEAH. AND GIULIANA
REVEALED THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
SHE LEARNED WAS TO BE
PERSISTENT BUT NOT ANNOYING
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TOOLS.
BUSINESS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET WORK. SO THAT'S HOW IS. OF
HOW HI SKILLS PROGRAM WORK TO.
UNDER RECORD IN. WILL GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY COMPETE FOR JOBS
IN THIS INDUSTRY. PROGRAM THREE
POINT OH ALSO REQUIRES TAX
CREDIT PROJECTS TO SUBMIT A
SUMMARY OF THEIR VOLUNTARY
PROGRAMS TO INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES. PRODUCERS
CONSISTENTLY STATE THAT THEY
ARE FOCUSED ON INCREASING
REPRESENTATION AMONG WRITERS
DIRECTORS THE CAST AND THE
CREW. AND A DESCRIPTION OF
THESE PROGRAMS WAS GIVEN TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND IT'S ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE CSC WEBSITE.
SO JUST TO WRAP IT UP THE FILM
COMMISSION ADMINISTERS THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
CREDITS TO CONTINUE TO GROW
FILM AND TV PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA. I DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENT CAREER READINESS
INITIATIVE AND PILOT SKILLS
TRAINING PROGRAM ALL PROMOTE
INCLUSIVENESS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS TO
LEARN TRAIN AT TEN THE
CREDENTIALS CREDENTIALS NEEDED.
FOR CAREERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT UP WE HAVE
ARLEN VAL THEM VIA THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION WHO
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE SIX
MAJOR HOLLYWOOD STUDIOS DISNEY
LET NETFLIX PARAMOUNT SONY
UNIVERSAL AND WARNER BROTHERS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN GONZALEZ
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE PART OF THE SIM CARD
DISCUSSION AND TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE THE VIRTUAL STAYED WITH
SO MANY AMAZING LIKE THE BASS.
MY NAME IS ARGHA MEDINA AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION AND OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES. MPA'S
COMMITTED TO ENCOURAGING GREAT
STORYTELLING THE REFLECTS THE
VIEWPOINTS AND EXPERIENCES OF
ALL CREATORS AND AUDIENCES
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE WORKING
HARD WITH OUR MEMBER STUDIOS TO
ADDRESS DIVERSITY GENDER PARITY
AUTHENTIC CULTURE
REPRESENTATION. PIPELINE OR
CRIMINAL RETURNEES FROM UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ARE. BY
PUBLISHING PROGRAMS THAT
PROMOTE A DIVERSE TALENT
PIPELINE. AND CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS AND SHARING WHAT
WE LEARN WE ARE LEADING BY
EXAMPLE. ONE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT WE GET THE M. P. PLAYING
IS INSURING THAT YOU'RE SHOWING
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA TO
DEMONSTRATE. THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSE AUDIENCES TO THE
ECONOMICS OF THE INDUSTRY. PART
OF OUR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IS THAT THE HER PARK. OUR
ANNUAL ANALYSIS AND SURVEY OF
THE THEATRICAL AND HOME
ENTERTAINMENT MARKET
ENVIRONMENT. ONE NOTABLE TAKE
AWAY FROM RECENT RECORDS THAT
THE AUDIENCES ARE AMONG ONE OF
THE NATION'S BIGGEST MOVIE
THAT. ACCOUNTING FOR OUTSIDE
SHARE THE BOX OFFICE RUN.
RELATIVE TO THEIR PORTION OF
THE POPULATION. THIS DATA HELPS.
TO THE BUSINESS CASE FOR
STRONGER DIVERSITY EFFORTS AND
RECENT YEARS HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT COMMERCIAL SUCCESS
FOR MOVIE SUCH AS BLACK PANTHER
SPIDER MAN INTO THE SPIDER
VERSE. COCOA CRAZY RICH ASIANS
AND THE FAST AND FURIOUS
FRANCHISE AND NOT TO MENTION
LAST YEAR'S BEST PICTURE MINOR
PARASITE. BROTHER VALIDATING
THE BUSINESS CASE FOR DIVERSITY
RIGHT TELLING. WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT. WHAT'S MORE IS NINE
YEARS AGO THE MPA ESTABLISHED
OUR OWN DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION PROGRAM THREE YEARS
BEFORE. RIGHT FIVE YEARS BEFORE
THE JOINT HEADS UP BECAUSE OUR
MEMBERS PROPERLY SUPPORTED THE
MPA CLAIMED A CONSTRUCTIVE ROLE
IN FORGING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK TO
DIVERSIFY THE CREATIVE PIPELINE
IN OUR INSURANCE DEPARTMENT
CONSTITUENCIES STUDIOS
POLICYMAKERS MULTICULTURAL
CRATER INNOVATIONS CAN'T
COMMUNICATE COLLABORATE
SHARPLES. TODAY OUR COALITION A
MULTI CULTURAL PARTNERS HAS
GROWN TO ALMOST FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS WITH A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON INCREASED ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A LOT NEXT
MEETING. BUT OF COURSE WHAT
MATTERS MORE IS WHERE MEMBERS
TOGETHER JOINT. WE ARE PROUD
EACH STUDIO AT THE MPA HAS ITS
OWN ROBUST CORPORATE POLICIES
SENIOR LEVEL DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION FOCUS PERSONNEL AND
OTHER PROGRAMS TO DIVERSIFY
INTEGRATED PIPELINE UNSPON AND
BOSSERT REPRESENTED
STORYTELLING. AND I KNOW I ONLY
HAVE A FEW MINUTES- BUT I
QUICKLY WANT TO SHOWCASE SOME
OF THE AMAZING WORK OUR MEMBERS
ARE DOING AND THIS IS JUST THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG I CAN SPEND
AN HOUR OR MORE TALKING ABOUT
THE GREAT PROGRAM'S MISSION. BY
VS. AS A ROBUST SET OF
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
INITIATIVES ACROSS ALL OF ITS
PLATFORMS INCLUDING PARAMOUNT
STUDIOS. CBS STUDIOS IN HIS
SPEECH HE MEDICAL CAN. MORE
ACCURATELY. ACCURATELY REFLECT
DIVERSITY BOTH ONSCREEN AND
BEHIND THE CAMERA. YES HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT IN ITS
DEVELOPMENT AND WRITERS ROOM BY
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SEASON 25% OF THE
SCRIPTED ELEMENT BUDGET WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO DIVERSE CREATORS.
AND 40% OF THE WRITERS WILL BE
pFUND FOR CREATIVE EQUITY TO
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS OF OUR PRESENT
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
THEY WILL INVEST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS AND A COMBINATION OF
EXTERNAL ORGANIZATIONS WITH
STRONG TRACK RECORDS. OF
STANDING UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES AFTER SUCCESS IN TV
AND FILMS AS WELL AS BESPOKE
NETWORK PROGRAMS. THAT WILL
HELP IDENTIFY AND TRAIN AND
PROVIDE JOB PLACEMENT FOR UP
AND COMING TALENT GLOBALLY.
ATTENTION WILL BE PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON BLACK INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN LGBTQ.
PLUS COMMUNITY AND DIFFERENTLY
ABLED PEOPLE. PROMISE ME DAD
BUT SOME PICTURES ENTERTAINMENT
HAS UNDERTAKEN A MULTI. PRONGED
APPROACH TO DIVERSITY INCLUSION
IN EVERY AREA OF ITS BUSINESS
BY LEVERAGING DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES FROM ITS
FILMMAKERS TO ITS CONTENT TO
MANAGERS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
MOST NOTABLY SONY'S DIVERSE
DIRECTORS PROGRAM NOW IN ITS
SEVENTH YEAR AS AN ABLE TO
STUDIO TRIDENTINE FIGHT MERGING
DIRECTORS FROM HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATION
INCLUDING WOMEN AND PEOPLE FROM
DIVERSE ETHNIC. BACKGROUNDS NOW
RESULT IN A NUMBER AND NUMEROUS
PROGRAMS GRADUATES ACTIVELY
DIRECTING FOR SONY PICTURES
AND- HISTORY ABOUT THE INDUSTRY.
WARNERMEDIA APPROACH TO
INCLUSION ACROSS PROGRAM AND
CONTENT IS FOCUSED ON ON SCREEN
REPRESENTATION CALL TO BEING
STORYTELLERS AND GROWING THEIR
PRODUCTION GREAT PIPELINE AT
ONE MEDIA THE OTHER HISTORY OF
PARTNERING WITH PRODUCERS AND
CREATORS. CONTENT CREATORS TO
ENSURE CREPE GREATER DIVERSITY
IN STORYTELLING IN THE
FOLLOWING UPCOMING PROJECTS.
WE'RE ALL VERY EXCITED ABOUT WE
CANNOT WAIT JUNE ELEVENTH-
THEY'RE ALSO HAVING A LOT NEXT
REMIX OF OTHER OF THE BRIDE
DEVELOPMENT WRITTEN BY MATT
LOPEZ SASHA HI IT JUST. WAS
JUST CAST AS DC'S UNIVERSE
FIRST EVER TO BE A SUPER GIRL
STARRING IN THE UPCOMING FILM
THE FLASH AND DIRECT DROPPING
MY MIND'S AUTHORIZING THE
MOMENT BLUE BEETLE. SPECIES
FIRST. NBC IN. I WANT A BROAD
RANGE OF DIVERSE TALENT
WRITERS. OUT PROGRAMS FOR
WRITERS DIRECTORS COMPOSERS AND
MARCH IDENTIFIED ENGAGE GREAT
TALENT FROM A WIDE. WIDE ARRAY
OF BACKGROUNDS. ANYTHING YOU IS
A PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT GINA
DAVIS. OFFENDER AND YET. AND
THEY U. S. US SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING GLOBAL TALENT AND
INCLUSION AND IS PILOTING A
SPELL CHECK PROVIDES RESOURCES.
TO HELP SUPPORT MORE AUTHENTIC
LATIN ACTS ONSCREEN
REPRESENTATION AND CASTING
OPPORTUNITIES DURING THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. GREAT APPETIZERS I'M
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM. TO HELP DEVELOP
SOFTWARE. LOU AND PRETTY KATE
PASS THE- HARNESS- COFOUNDER BY
FOR. XIN BROWN'S OR PUT A- LORD
WHEELER PACKER PUT AND THEN
YOUR LEADING ON POSSIBLE. AND
THE WALT DISNEY COMPANY HAS
MANY PRO AND POLICY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND TO DIVERSIFY
THE GREEN LINE INCLUDING THE
LONG STANDING CREATIVE TALENT
DEVELOPMENT THAT HAS HELPED
LAUNCH THE CAREER MANY INDUSTRY
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING A
WRITER PRODUCER RIGHT THAT AND
DIRECTORS OF ENOUGH ON THIS AND
THEN YOU LAUNCH PAD PROGRAM
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED DIRECTORS. TO
CREATE CONTENT FOR THEIR DUTY
PLUS STREAMING SERVICE AND
RECENTLY. ANNOUNCED COMMITMENT
TO INCLUSION STANDARDS EVERYONE
HERE SHARES THE GOAL OF
PROMOTING ITS RIGHT TELLING
THAT REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
THE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE
ESPECIALLY THAT THE EXPERIENCE
AND TOGETHER I'M CONFIDENT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THERE ARE
LOTS OF WAYS ALL STORIES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME AND I SPOKE TO
PASS IT'S MY HALF MEXICAN.
AVOCADO AND THAT YOU KNOW. WE
ALL. MEMBER I WANT MAKE SURE
THE ALL GET THE SAME. WE ALSO
BE TOO FAST IT'S OKAY AS- THANK
WE HAVE ONE MORE OUR PNELISTS-
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM BRENDA
VICTORIA BECAUSE THE- THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
NATIONAL HISPANIC MEDIA
COALITION. BRENDA. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LORENA GONZALEZ AND
SELECT COMMITTEE. ONLINE FINA
INEQUITIES I AM SO THRILLED TO
BE HERE TODAY WITH ALL OF YOU
AMAZING AND POWERFUL WOMEN OF
INFLUENCE. I AM BUT IN THE
VICTORIA CASTEEL THE FIRST
FEMALE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF AN
HMC I AM GLAD TO NEXT NATIVE
WOMAN MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE HER
AREA. AND I'M COMING TO YOU
FROM WHITTIER CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS TALK ABOUT LAND. THE
NATIONAL HISPANIC MEDIA
COALITION WAS. FOUNDED THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO IN ORDER TO
ELIMINATE HATE DISCRIMINATION
AND RACISM TOWARDS THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WE EDUCATE AND
INCREASED VISIBILITY OF LATINOS
FROM OUR POLICY WORK IN
WASHINGTON DC TO OUR MEDIA
ADVOCACY WORK IN HOLLYWOOD.
WHERE WE COLLABORATE CREATE AND
CONNECT LATTER NEXT TALENT WITH
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL HISPANIC CAUCUS
AND I HEARD SOMEBODY EARLIER
TALK ABOUT CONGRESSMAN. JOAQUIN
CASTRO WHO HAS LED THE FIGHT.
AT ANYTIME SEE WE FOCUS ON ALL
FORMS OF MEDIA BECAUSE IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
INSTITUTIONS THAT AFFECTS.
ATTITUDES VALUES AND BELIEFS OF
SOCIETY HOW LEAD TO NEXT ARE
REPRESENTED IS HOW WE ARE
TREATED IN REAL LIFE AND WE ARE
NOT TREATED VERY WELL. YOU CAN
DRAW A LINE FROM THE PERVASIVE
LACK OF POSITIVE LATINO
REPRESENTATION ON THE SCREEN TO
THE RISE OF HATE CRIMES AGAINST
OUR COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE
MASSACRE THAT TOOK PLACE IN AND
ALSO THE HOUSE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THERE IS A DANGEROUS
CONNECTION BETWEEN RACIST
RHETORIC AND THE NEGATIVE
IMAGES OF LATINOS AS CRIMINALS
AND INVADERS THAT AMERICANS SEE
ON THE SCREEN. WHEN TRUMP IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SAID THAT
MEXICANS WERE CRIMINALS AND
RAPISTS HATE CRIME WENT UP AND
THAT'S JUST NOT ME THAT SAYING
THIS THESE ARE FBI REPORTS.
SOMETIMES WERE NOT REPRESENTED
AT ALL WE ARE EXCLUDED. THERE
ARE SOME SHOWS RIGHT NOW ON THE
AIR. WHETHER IT'S TELEVISION OR
STREAMING THERE ARE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE ARE MORE THAN
50% OF THE POPULATION YET NOT
ONE RECURRING LATIN NEXT
CHARACTER OR NOT ONE LATIN NEXT
WRITER IN THE ROOM. WHEN OUR
CHILDREN DO NOT SEE THEMSELVES
UP ON THE BIG SCREEN OR IF THEY
DON'T SEE IT OR IF THEY ONLY
SEE THEMSELVES IN NEGATIVE
ROLES IMAGINE WHAT THAT DOES
TO. A CHILD'S PSYCHE. IT WOULD
MEAN SO MUCH IN THIS ROOM THIS
IS WHAT HURT ME THE MOST IT
WOULD MEAN SO MUCH FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO SEE THEMSELVES ON
THE BIG SCREEN. SO THEY CAN
BELIEVE IN THEMSELVES. BECAUSE
IF YOU SEE IT YOU CAN BE AT. SO
THIS IS WHY NEARLY TWENTY YEARS
AGO AN AGENCY. CREATED
EDUCATIONAL AND WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. LIKE THE SERIES
SCRIPT WRITERS PROGRAM AND THE
LATIN EXTREME SHOWCASE THEY
CREATES COLLABORATES IT
CONNECTS THE LATIN NEXT TALENT
WITH THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. WE HAVE HAD MANY
LATINOS WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
OUR PROGRAM WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
OUR PROGRAM. AND IT'S VERY
SUCCESSFUL C. AT OUR NELLIS.
WHO IS EXECUTIVE PRODUCER AND
HER SHOWED HER SERIES JUST
STARTED RUTHERFORD FALLS SILVIO
LEVI S. WHOSE EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER OF A LINE UP ABA LORD
NOW SHE'S WITH NETFLIX. AND YOU
READY HEARD TODAY FROM TWO TO
LENA SHE'S ARE ALLOWED. ZAIDA
ED WROTE FOR THE ONE NOT AND
SELENA THE CERES HIRED. TWO OF
OUR FEMALE WRITERS JESSICA
LOPEZ OF PAMELA GARCIA RUNNING.
BUT IF I CAN JUST LEAVE YOU
WITH THIS BECAUSE IN HANDY IN
ORDER FOR LATINOS TO BE FULLY
REPRESENTED IN MEDIA WE NEED TO
GET US AT THE MOST HIGHEST
LEVEL OF INFLUENCE AND POWER
LIKE THE BOARD ROOM. PRESIDENT
AND CEO POSITIONS AND MEDIAL
OWNERSHIP. MOST OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA WERE MORE
THAN 40% OF THE POPULATION AND
A LOT OF THEM ARE LOCATED RIGHT
HERE IN ALLEN COUNTY WHERE WE
ARE MORE THAN 50% OF THE
POPULATION. I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN
CALIFORNIA THE TALKED ABOUT
CORPORATIONS HAVING. UNDER A
ONE UNDER REPRESENTATIVE BOARD
OF DIRECTOR. ON THEIR BOARDING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SINCE THAT BILL PASSED WOMEN
HAVE INCREASETHE NUMBER WOMEN
HAVE INCREASED 40% BUT LATINOS
ARE ONLY 3% SO WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL AND ALWAYS ON THE
WORDS THAT WERE USING ONLY USE
DIVERSE CITY INCLUSION UNDER
REPRESENTATIVE BECAUSE MANY
TIMES WHEN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT WOMEN. THEY'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT LETTING US AND WE
ARE WOMEN. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. THANK YOU AND
WHAT A PERFECT SEGUE- ONE OF
THE REASONS WE HAVE THIS
COMMITTEE IS BECAUSE WE KNOW
FOR CHANGE TO HAPPEN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT LATINOS- WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF DIVERSITY INITIATIVES
THAT I THINK IS THE FIRST PANEL
SAID. LATINAS AREN'T SEEN AS
DIVERSE FOR WHATEVER REASON
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE
ELSE IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE PASSED RULES ABOUT
DIVERSITY ON BOARDS- IT STILL
HAS NOT THAT LATINOS ARE THE
MOST UNDER REPRESENTED EVEN
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO GET WOMEN
ON BOARDS. OR ON. FULL OF COLOR
ON BOARD SO WHERE IT. WE GOT A
FIGHT- FOR THAT INTENTIONALITY-
JUST JUST TO TRY TO BECOME MORE
REPRESENTATIVE. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR ARLEN AND IT
PRETTY MUCH HAS TO DO WITH HOW
WE ENDED THAT. SO MUCH OF THE
DISCUSSION IS ALWAYS FOCUSED
ON- IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
PRODUCTION.THOSE JOBS OFTEN
INVOLVE SKILLED CRAFTSPEOPLE
SPECIAL TRADES BUT THERE'S SO
MANY JOBS WITHIN THE STUDIOS IN
THE OFFICES THAT ARE ENTRY
LEVEL JOBS WHERE SOMEONE COULD
LEARN IN ADVANCE. WHAT ARE THE
STUDIOS DOING TO GET LEVINE AS
INTO THE FRONT OFFICE JOBS. I'M
SO GLAD THAT YOU ASPECTS I
THINK I'M LOOKING AT THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY MOST
PEOPLE THINK. YOU KNOW WRITERS
PRODUCERS DIRECTORS ACTORS AND
THE ENERGY MINISTRY HAS-
ECOSYSTEM RIGHT THERE'S LAWYERS
ACCOUNTANTS THERE'S TRASH
THERE'S THAT MEDICS THERE'S-
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT- JOBS
AND- EACH OF THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS HAVE NUMEROUS
INTERNSHIPS FELLOWSHIPS- AND
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW. FOLKS TO
COME IN ON THE CORPORATE LEVEL
EXECUTIVE LEVEL- AND SO I'M-
HAPPY TO WALK THROUGH ALL OF
THEM BUT WHAT SIX MEMBER
COMPANIES. LIMIT ABOUT TIME- I
CAN'T LIST THEM ALL BUT I DO
KNOW THAT ALL THE FOR ALL OF
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE. YES
PROGRAMS TO. HAVE PEOPLE COME
INTO THE PIPELINE AND I'M HAPPY
TO SET A TIME WITH YOU ARE THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WHAT
THE WHAT THE PROGRAMS ARE. WE
WOULD LOVE TO GET PRO I THINK
DETAILED- ACCOUNTING OF THE
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
LOOKING. TOWARDS THE FUTURE OF
ANY KIND OF- FUTURE TAX CREDIT
THAT THAT WE'RE DESIGNING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK THE
DIVERSITY ASPECT IS ONE WE NEED
TO REALLY DRILL DOWN ON SO THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. REMOVE ON
SAYS THAT YOU HAD A QUESTION.
YES THANK YOU. I'M SO A USC
STUDY FOUND THAT FILMS WITH
UNDER REPRESENTED LEEDS AND
COLLEAGUES RECEIVE LESS
RESOURCES THAN FILMS WITH WHITE
LEADS. CAN YOU SPEAK TO THIS IS
THERE ANY BACKGROUND YOU CAN
PROVIDE AS TO HOW. PRODUCTION
BUDGETS ARE ALLOCATED TO FILM
CENTERED AROUND UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
LATINOS AND LATINAS. AND CAN
YOU SPEAK TO HOW PROJECTS ARE
GREEN LIGHTED AND BUDGETS. ARE
APPROVED AND LASTLY WHAT CAN WE
DO. BEYOND THE TAX CREDIT THAT
WILL HELP US RETAIN MORE OF OUR
INDUSTRY AND CALIFORNIA AS
OTHER STATES. ARE TRYING TO
COMPETE WITH CALIFORNIA- LIKE
GEORGIA. AND WHAT WOULD YOU BE
ON THE TAX CREDIT TO BE MORE
COMPETITIVE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
GROWING INDUSTRY. I CAN TAKE A
STAB AT THAT I MEAN I COULD
WRITE PERSONALLY CAN'T SPEAK TO
HOW INDIVIDUAL GREEN LIGHTING
AND RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED FOR
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION- BUT WE
DO BELIEVE THAT DIVERSITY
SHOULD BE IN CONSIDERATION WITH
GREEN WRITING PROCESS. I'M A
PROUD OF THE ROLE AGAIN THAT WE
PLAY IN PROVIDING SORT OF THAT
DATA THAT ALLOWS FOR. MAKING
THE BUSINESS CASE FOR MORE
DIVERSE STORYTELLING- AND
CALIFORNIA'S LUCKY THAT WE'VE
GOT GREAT CLIMATE AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF GEOGRAPHY- BUT I THINK
OUTSIDE OF THE TAX CREDIT I
THINK IT'S ALSO THE SKILLS. OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE I'M
INVESTING IN PROGRAMS LIKE THE
NATIONAL SPENT NEED A COLLATION
FIGHT NOT LEAVE LIKE GET A FORM
SCHOOL OF HOLLYWOOD CPR ONLY
BUILD THE TALENT. PIPELINE FOR
US TO RECOUP FROM. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE. PLEASE I THINK
THAT- IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS TO
HAVE INCREDIBLE CAREERS IN THE
MOTION PICTURE INDUSTRY WE ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT INITIATIVE
BECAUSE WE REALIZE THAT A LOT
OF- STUDENTS IN HIGH SCHOOL
DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE DRUGS ARE
AND SO ARE CAREER READINESS
PROGRAM IS AIMED AT EXPOSING
THEM TO THESE JOBS WHICH IS ONE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
AND THE OTHER A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. OUTREACH TO
FAMILIES WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT WHILE WE MAY GET STUDENTS
EXCITED ABOUT JOBS IN THE
INDUSTRY THEIR PARENTS DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE
AN INCREDIBLE CAREER IN THE
FILM BUSINESS AND THEY DON'T
CONSIDER WORKING NUMBERS S.
PERHAPS AND SAID GOOD JOB-
OPTION FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
STUDENTS SO I THINK WE NEED TO
ALSO OUTREACH TO PARENTS AND
FAMILIES SO THEY UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST FOR
INSTANCE VISUAL FAXES ONE AREA
THAT HAS YOU KNOW RECENT THREE
HUNDRED PERCENT. IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS IN TERMS OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND YOU KNOW
EVERYONE WHO'S SEEN YOU KNOW
SPIDER MAN PERHAPS DOESN'T
REALISE THAT FOR ONE SHOT IT
MAY HAVE TAKEN THIRTY PEOPLE TO
GO FROM THE ORIGINAL IDEA OF IT
ALLTHE WAY TO THE CREATION OF
THE SHOT THAT YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN THERE ARE SO MANY BELOW
THE LINE CREATIVE AND TECHNICAL
JOBS THAT EXIST THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT EVEN AWARE OF. AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO DO A LOT OF
OUR REGION EDUCATION SO THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THESE JOBS
ARE THERE AND YOU KNOW WE. CAN
TRAIN THEM FOR THOSE DROPS. AND
THE YES. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
YOU KNOW I EIGHT IN PREPARING
FOR THIS HEARING AT AND ALSO
INCREDIBLY TIMELY THAT THE
SUNDAY. ARE THE OSCARS AND THE
OSCARS ARE TAKING PLACE AT
UNION STATION AND IN MY
DISTRICT. AND THERE'S AN
INCREDIBLE ARTICLE IN THE LA
TIMES- TITLE YES THE OSCAR
NOMINATIONS ARE MORE DIVERSE
BUT THEY LARGELY LEAVE OUT
LATINOS AND I FOUND THAT TO BE
REALLY FASCINATING AND THAT-
BEFORE THERE'S THE TRENDING
HASHTAG OSCARS SO WHITE THAT'S
BEEN. PREVALENT FOR THE PAST
FEW YEARS NOW AND IT'S GREAT TO
SEE OUR VIOLA DAVIS BECOMES THE
MOST NOMINATED BLACK ACTRESS
WITH HER LEAD ROLE FOR MA
RAINEY'S BLACK BOTTOM STEVEN U.
N. IS NOW THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN LEAD ACTOR NOMINATED
FOR HIS WORK AND MANARI. REESE
AHMAD IS- HOLD THE DISTINCTION
FOR BEING THE FIRST MUSLIM TO
BE NOMINATED FOR LEAD ACTOR FOR
HIS ROLE IN SOUND OF METAL. AND
THERE'S SO MANY GREAT EXAMPLES.
BUT THERE ARE NO ALL LATINOS
AND NOW AS SPECIFICALLY NOTED
THAT THE MATH AND THE ONLY
CATEGORY IN WHICH WE SEE- THE
LATIN ACTS OR LET ME KNOW
EXPERIENCE ARE IN THE CATEGORY
OF FOREIGN FILMS. FROM LATIN
AMERICA- INTERNATIONAL FOREIGN
FILMS AND SO IT'S INTERESTING
TO SEE TO NOTE THAT DESPITE-
THE CONSUMPTION OF LATINOS
WHICH HAS BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT ON
ON THIS HEARING IN TERMS OF-
ESPECIALLY THE FAST AND FURIOUS
FRANCHISE WHICH IS- YOU KNOW
BUT THERE WAS A STUDY MIDDLE A
WHILE AGO THAT LET THE NOSE.
CONTINUE TO WATCH THE THOSE
THEORIES BECAUSE WE LOVE FAST
CARS AND IF THE IF THE GREAT OF
THE FILM FRANCHISE. BUT THAT
EVEN IN THE OSCARS NOMINATION
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE SEE
OURSELVES IS ACTUALLY FORMED.
NOW AMERICAN. RIGHT IT'S LIKE
THE LATIN EXPERIENCE IS
OUTSIDE. AND SO I IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A QUESTION FOR
EVERYONE JUST A THOUGHT AND IF
YOU CAN IF YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ON
THAT I FIND IT FSCINATING IN
TERMS OF. CHANGING THE
NARRATIVE FOR LESS ENOUGH
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES WITHIN
THE STORIES THAT ARE TOLD ABOUT
US BEING IN THIS COUNTRY. THE
INTERNATIONAL AN INTERSECTIONAL
EXPERIENCES OF LATINOS AND
STORYTELLING. A VIDA THE WHICH
WE HEARD FROM EARLIER IS FILMED
IN MY DISTRICT- AND SO IT'S-
AND IT HAS A LOT OF VIBRANCY IN
TERMS OF OUR EXPERIENCES AS-
MEXICAN AMERICANS ARE CHICANOS
ARE LIVE NEXT- AND I JUST FIND
IT FASCINATING THAT. DESPITE
ALL THAT. EVEN IN THE OSCARS.
WERE STILL ON SCENE HERE. I'M
CURIOUS OF THE PANELISTS HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE IT'S ALSO SO TIMELY. NO
NO. YEAH JUST JUST ABOUT IS
IT'S OK I THINK BRANDON WANTS
TO SAY SOMETHING BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF OUR BIKES ARE NOT. YOU
KNOW I LIKE. MY MIND BUT WHAT I
WANT TO SAY IS WELL FIRST OF
ALL SHAMEFUL RIGHT. I MEAN
RIGHT HERE IN LOS ANGELES THE
OSCARS ARE TAKING PLACE A YEAR
AFTER YEAR IS A CURSE. I HAVE
TO SAY- IT WAS APRIL RAIN THE
CAME UP WITH THE HASHTAG OSCARS
SO WHITE AND I WAS TRYING TO
REMEMBER RIGHT NOW- AFRICAN
AMERICAN ACTOR WHO CAME OUT HE
SAID HE'S BOYCOTTING THE
OSCARS. HE'S NOT GOING TO
ATTEND HE DIDN'T ASK ANYBODY'S
PERMISSION HEATING GO TO AN
ORGANIZATION FOR SUPPORT HE
JUST CAME OUT AND SAID.
SOMETIMES I FEEL WE DO NOT HAVE.
THAT. ONE POWERFUL VOICE THAT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE INDUSTRY THAT'S
NOT AFRAID IF THEY SPEAK UP
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT BECAUSE THE PHONE
STOPPED RINGING. I FEEL WE
DON'T HAVE THAT REPRESENTATIVE
I WANT TO HEAR FROM EVERYBODY
ELSE BUT I. YOU KNOW WE CAN
ONLY DO SO MUCH ANYTIME C. HAS
BOYCOTTED THE OSCARS WE HAVE
PROTEST IT AND PICK IT TOO. BUT
WHERE AN ADVOCACY GROUP. WHERE
IS THAT ONE PERSON OF INFLUENCE.
IT'S WELL WE'RE NOT NOW DIRT
AROUND THE WORLD. THAT'S LATIN
ACTS WILL SPEAK UP. YEAH BRENDA
THAT IS SO POWERFUL AND SO
IMPORTANT WHILE YOU'RE PUTTING.
AND I'M EVEN AGREED TO
PARTICIPATE IN IN DIFFERENT
TIMES GOT AFRAID TO
PARTICIPATE- AND I THINK THAT'S
TELLING I THINK YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE A THAT VOICE THAT
PROTECTS OTHER VOICES- TO SPEAK
UP IN A SENSE AS WELL THAT THAT
MEGASTAR VOICE IF YOU WILL TO
PROTECT OTHERS WHO KNOW THERE'S
A PROBLEM. BUT REALIZE THAT IF
THEY BECOME THE TROUBLE MAKER
IT MAY AFFECT THEIR CAREER SO-
IT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE
STRUGGLE WITH IN GENERAL THE
LATINO COMMUNITY AND- BUT IN
THIS IN THIS PLACE IN
PARTICULAR. MADAM CHAIR DID YOU
SAY THEY WERE FEARFUL TO COME
ON UHHUH YEAH WE HAD A NUMBER
OF MY **** WHO YOU KNOW- WE'RE
INTERESTED TALK TO US ABOUT
ABOUT PROTESTING GIVE US
BACKGROUND BUT DIDN'T WANT TO
SPEAK- AND YOU KNOW IT THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE I IT AGAIN I
COME FROM ORGANIZING WORKERS
AND SO THAT'S SO TYPICALAND
ANY INDUSTRY- THEY KNOW THERE'S
A PROBLEM BUT THEY DON'T WANT
ANY YOU KNOW IT OF COURSE YOU
WOULD NEVER WANT- YOUR CAREER
AFFECTED OR- THERE THERE WERE
JUST AT. A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT WERE TOLD TO US SO I THINK
I JUST THINK THAT'S TELLING- IN
THIS INDUSTRY I REMEMBER. I
REMEMBER WITH SPIKE LEE SPIKE
LEE CAME OUT AND SAID I'M
BOYCOTTING THE OSCARS OWN. WAIT
WHILE DANTE. YEAH WELL WE'RE
STILL LOOKING- FOR IT WE
SHOULDN'T GET TO THAT POINT I
MEAN AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
WE SHOULD GET TO THAT POINT
I'VE I'M GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW- IN INTAKE I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE ANY COULD
PUBLIC COMMENT THE QUEUE-
DRIVEN. TRADITIONAL OPERATOR.
OKAY WE WILL LOOK OPERATORS OR
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT VIA
THE PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT FOR A FIRST COME. I'M
SORRY THE PERSON WHO QUEUED UP-
MISTER PRESSED ONE ZERO AGAIN-
AND THAT THE REMOVED YOU FROM
THE COMMENT CARE SO IF YOU WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ONE MORE TIME. ONE
MOMENT FOR A FIRST COMMENT.
PROBLEMS WITH THE PHONE LINE.
NINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M FROM
SUFFOLK COUNTY CALIFORNIA IT'S
AMAZING THAT LORENA GONZALEZ IS
ALLOWED TO BRING THIS TO THE
FLOOR DEBATE PLEASE CUT THIS IS
NOT IF SOMEBODY WOULD LIKE COME
BASED ON THE- PUBLIC NO I
RETURN WHAT YOU NEED IS AND
THAT. IT WE NOT. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TOLERATE BECAUSE WHO
AREN'T CALL INTO PARK STREET
DISCUSS IF YOU'D LIKE TO- AND I
JUST STATING NAME YOUR ORGAN-
THAT'S FINE IF NOT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS THAT WE OFTEN DEAL
WITH IN THESE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. OPERATORS ARE ANY
OTHER COLORS. NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME WONDERFUL I WILL
BRING IT BACK FOR SOME CLOSING
DISCUSSION- BY THE MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS- TODAY IT THIS WAS I
OPENING FOR ME YEAH IT WAS A
REALLY. AT I OPENING HOPEFUL
DISHEARTENING ALL AT THE SAME
TIME I WANT TO NOTE- I MADE
THIS MISTAKE I STARTED OFF ON
THIS MISTAKE TODAY AND JUST
STUCK WITH IT I DO NOT MEAN TO
DISRESPECT MY FILIPINOS BY
CALLING THEM BY THEIR FIRST
NAME THEY'RE ALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS. I JUST
STARTED BY DOING THAT WE'RE
HAVING A CALL. SO I CAN. BUT
I'M WE OFTEN FACE THAT ARE FROM
PEOPLE SO I WANT BE SURE THEY-
MIGHT MIGHT I POINT IN DOING
THAT WAS WE'RE JUST HAVING A
DISCUSSION IF. IT'S SOMETIMES
HARD BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
FRIENDS AND WE FORGET WHERE WE
ARE BUT THIS WAS A FABULOUS
DISCUSSION AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT- AS WITH ALL OF OUR
HEARINGS. WE HAVE ONE EXCEPTION
BECAUSE IT COULD BECAUSE
NANCY'S OVER THE FILM
COMMISSION BUT OTHERWISE. ALL
THE PRESENTERS WERE LOOKING AT
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE END
SCENE LEVINE A PROJECT BECAUSE
THE INITIATIVE SHOWS THAT YES
WE ARE UNDER REPRESENTED WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO. BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO SHOWCASE THAT
WERE OUT THERE WE HAVE THE
RESEARCHERS WE HAVE OF THE
ACADEMICS WHO DONE THE WORK WE
HAVE. THAT THE PEOPLE IN EVERY
SINGLE ASPECT BEFORE THEN FROM
THE CAMERA BEHIND THE CAMERA
WRITING WE HAVE WOMEN WHO ARE
HEADING ORGANIZATIONS IN
ADVOCATING FOR THIS AND IT THE
MOVIES AT THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION SO. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO POINT THAT
OUT BECAUSE- WHEN YOU ARE
INTENTIONAL INSANE- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE QUALIFIED LEVINE IS
OUT THERE GUESS WHAT YOU CAN
FIND THEM WE ALWAYS STILL
INSIDE WHEN I THINK THE
PANELISTS TODAY WHO
PARTICIPATED WHO AT. ONCE
AGAIN. HELP US SHOWCASE THE
BROAD TALENT WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY- SO THAT. WELL BE
BRIEF YOU KNOW THE FIRST PART.
AND FIRST STEP IN. MAKING
CHANGE AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE
IS A SHINING LIGHT ON AN ISSUE
AND ON THE PROBLEM AND I JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD THE COMMITTEE
ALL OF THE PANELISTS- FOR
STEPPING UP FOR SOME OF HIS
BEING THE FIRST AND ACROSS A
VARIETY OF INDUSTRIES IT'S
REALLY HARD TO BE THE FIRST AND
I'M JUST THANKFUL TO BE- ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO ALSO BE A
PART OF SHINING A LIGHT ON THE
INEQUITIES FOR LETTING US
AROUND CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
WHEN THEY YES I WANT TO THANK
OUR OUR CHAIRWOMAN
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE CONVERSATION. I
THINK A- I'LL JUST POKE A
LITTLE FUN AND SAY WHEN SOMEONE
SAID THAT SOME PARENTS DON'T
KNOW- YOU KNOW. THE IMPORTANCE
OF. OR HOW INCREDIBLE A CAREER
AND IN HOLLYWOOD FOR LETTING US
CAN BE I THINK YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING THAT. YOURSELF I
JUST YOU KNOW I WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO A FRIEND OF MINE
LAUREN PEREZ WHO IS ONE OF THE-
ORIGINAL ORGANIZERS WITH SAG
AFTRA WHO WAS. FLYING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN LOS ANGELES AND
MIAMI TO UNIONIZE THAT
ORGANIZED. THE LIMINAL SOAP
OPERA STARS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS PARITY BETWEEN.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE AMERICAN MADE
SOAP OPERAS AND- A SPANISH
LANGUAGE LANGUAGE AMERICAN
MYSELF UP FOR US AND SO IT'S-
DESPITE THE LANGUAGE
DIFFERENCE. THE PAY INEQUITY IS
STILL A CONVERSATION THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE HAD IN TERMS OF-
WHAT AT WHAT IS VALUED. AND
WHAT TALENT IS VALUED AND
REALLY AGAIN I WOULD ADD. THE
ADVERTISING DOLLARS TO COME
AROUND WANTED. TO ENSURE THAT A
SHOW WAS SUCCESSFUL IT'S ALSO
PART OF A LARGER CONVERSATION
AND ENSURING THAT. TELEVISION
STUDIOS AS WELL AS MOVIE
STUDIOS- REALLY PUT- MARKETING
DOLLARS BEHIND. SHOWS WHERE
THERE ARE LOTS THE NICE AS THE
LEAD CHARACTERS WERE THERE ARE
LATINOS AS- THE WRITERS WERE
THERE ARE LATINOS AS THE SHOW
RUNNERS. TO ENSURE THAT IT DOES
IT'S NOT SET UP TO FAIL. AND I
THINK THAT'S A BIG PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY. WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE CALIFORNIA TAX
CREDIT. AND ENSURING THAT THOSE
DIVERSITY NUMBERS ARE INCLUDED
IN REPORTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING AND TAX DOLLARS ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO. PROPER
REPRESENTATION. FOR THE STORIES
THAT WE SEE ON TV THE STORIES
THAT WE SEE. ON THE BIG SCREEN-
AND A NEW EMERGING MARKET FOR
DIGITAL PLATFORMS LIKE. HULU
AND NETFLIX AND- YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN AND SO
THERE'S- IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
SPACE RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW THAT WE
HAVE MORE LETTING US IN THE
LEGISLATURE. MORE WOMEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE MORE I. IN THE LEAD.
TO THAT. YOU KNOW WE PUT OUR
OUR VET. WHERE THEY MATTER. AND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PUSH
TOWARDS MORE EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA WHERE OUR STORIES
ARE TOLD BY US AND NOT BY
OTHERS SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE CONVERSATION I
LEARNED A LOT- AND I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DISCUSSION. THANK YOU MANY
OF ANNA COULD YOU LIKE TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ASK EACH
OF THE PANELISTS. TO SUBMIT ONE
THING THAT YOU THINK. OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD FOCUS ON.
AND THEN I WOULD COME IN AT
THAT THE LATINO CAUCUS WITH
TWENTY TO TWENTY NINE
LEGISLATORS. COULD ADOPT ANY
ONE OF THOSE AS A PRIORITY FOR
US TO MOVE FORWARD- AND- OF
COURSE. WITH A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ BUT- THERE WERE SO
MANY GREAT IDEAS THAT YOU ALL
BROUGHT UP SO MANY ISSUES YOU
BROUGHT UP BUT HELP US NARROW
IT DOWN. SO THAT WE COULD USE
OUR STRENGTH AND OUR VOICES AND
REPRESENTATION IN A MUCH MORE
FOCUSED WITH SO HELLO THANK OU
ALL VERY MUCH IT WAS REALLY
REALLY WONDERFUL. THANK YOU AND
WE WILL IT WILL POSE THAT
QUESTION TO ALL THE PANELS BUT
WE'LL DO IT IN WRITING SO THAT
YOU CAN REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT IS- THAT IS THE ONE THING
YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK TO. MAYBE A
FUTURE EXPANSION OF THE FILM
TAX CREDIT AS YOU LOOK TO
DIFFERENT THINGS WE CAN DO
LEGISLATIVELY WHAT IS THE ONE
THING WE COULD DO TO HELP-
ENSURE THAT THAT DIVERSITY
INCLUDES LATINOS- THAT
DIVERSITY. MATTERS THAT WE YOU
KNOW IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT WE START TO SEE-
SOME EQUITIES AS- SO WE WILL
POSE THAT IN WRITING AND GATHER
THOSE- AND WE WILL AT THE END
OF COURSE ARE AND SEEN THE TEAM
AS WE WILL HAVE AN OVERALL
REPORT. BUT BEFORE THEN THERE
ARE THINGS WE CAN DO WEEK WE DO
HAVE SOME POWER- LIMITED AS IT
MIGHT BE. WE HAVE SOME POWER TO
MAKE CHANGE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE SO. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
AND THE MEMBERS I KNOW KEVIN
MCCARTY WAS ON- HE TEXTED ME
FOR SOME REASON HE WASN'T
SHOWING UP ON MY SCREEN AS
WELL. AND I WAS KALRA WHO WAS
ON- AND I WNT TO THANK MY
STAFF FOR JASMINE WHO WORKED
REALLY HARD TO GET THAT PULL
THIS TOGETHER. SO THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND THANK
YOU EVERYBODY WHO CONTRIBUTED
TO THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION I LOOK. I LOOK
FORWARD TO PART TWO BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE NOT DONE WITH THIS
ONE. ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT AYE
ANY MONIES WE MAY SPENDING
CALIFORNIA. THE FUTURE SELF
THANK YOU SO MY AND HAVE A NICE
DAY. YEAH. GIVEN HOW MAY NOT
HAVE THE AFTER KIND OF TOOK IT.